what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
the pregame
start do not forget to subscribe to the
channel and ring that notification Bell
that way you're going to be notified of
my daily videos while you're at it guys
if you have watched two or more of my
videos and you do not subscribe you
already know we have beef okay beef
people so a couple announcements before
we start the show the first being is
that we have two clips channels we have
just pearly just pearly clips and pearl
daily make sure you go subscribe to both
on top of that we have four membership
tiers so the first membership tier you
get to be a part of the chat the second
membership tier you get to be a part of
the Discord and you are behind the
scenes Vlogs third tier you connect with
us on social media fourth tier you get a
one-on-one call with me once a month I
really recommend this if you need help
growing your YouTube channel I have
helped people get to 10 20 000 30 000
subscribers on YouTube I've helped
people grow on Tick Tock so I really
recommend this tier if you want to grow
on social media
on top of that make sure you go follow
my Instagram it's just dot pearly things
make sure you put the dot after just I
am Shadow bands you have to type out the
whole thing
um also guys I have two Tick Tock
accounts um because they took away my
first second and third Tick Tock so go
follow just pearlythings.4 and just
pearly thinks.5 and keep on the lookout
for just pearly thing six because I'll
probably make I don't know I think I
might get one taken soon
um also guys we are trying to get to
half a million subscribers before the
end of the month so make sure you go hit
that subscribe button
um and DM Eddie if you want to come on
the show his link is in the description
so um today I have a lovely panel um
some new faces some familiar why don't
we go around everyone say your name your
age your relationship status and a fun
fact about yourself starting here and
then go around then second row
so um my name is Nathan but everybody
call me Mr trust me I'm 30 years old I'm
single
and I'm from dagging them they call you
Mr trust me yeah for sure why well
because how how my energy is lacking
when I do my photo shoots like I
screamed the word out like the way how I
say it I'm always saying like Trust
like I get too high top in the photo
shoot you know what I'm saying Okay so
so they call you can I call you Mr trust
me okay okay I just want to make sure
okay go go ahead
oh me no uh my name is uh lucerito and
I'm a music model uh here in the UK I'm
33 and I'm in a very very happy
relationship
and I'm your girl Juicy J I am 29 I'm
single I live in London but I'm Nigerian
Italian I'm evil girl babe you know
shout out
and uh yeah what else
what's that oh fun fact I love cheese I
love food so much I made in my job
you Chef no I'm a dietitian or a
dietitian yeah I was gonna say you can
bring me some if you you know as in food
yeah yeah anything Italian and Nigerian
food which one would you like better oh
Nigeria Nigerian Foods hey okay have you
ever had it before though yeah okay then
we should go we should go somewhere
somewhere nice it's a nice restaurant oh
cool cool go ahead hi guys obviously
it's your favorite Troublemaker than
Alva I am 29. I am very happily single
and a fun fact
um
my choice of coloring outfits
educates my mood therefore I'm wearing
blue I might be nice to the voice today
hi guys I doubt it
hi guys my name is tandy Blues I'm 25
years old and I'm in a relationship and
fun factors
well I'm obsessed I told Pearl this the
first time I came in but I'm obsessed
with eating ice every night oh yeah
you're hydrated though
exactly God damn do you bite into
lollipops like like that yeah even high
school like I slowly sorry yeah all of
it you got good nerves in your mouth
hey guys Alexander
um 27
uh
from
London what else was because you gotta
go
um Bachelor
and fun fact would be
uh I was one of the top athletes for
high jump and hurdles back in high
school North London well done
Nigerians
[Laughter]
hi I'm Auntie Jenny 54.
very content in my relationship
fun facts I like trying different foods
African snails I've had French snails
about frog looks I've had ostrich ever
had
you've had ostrich yeah what is that
like oh it's lovely I prefer ostriches
to steak now oh really yeah poor ostrich
can you bring me some next time I'm just
trying to get some food yeah I'll bring
it
no one's Africans now
what you don't want the African snails
oh I'll try it I'll try anything it's
good okay
um so today's topic is should women fear
men and the reason I picked this topic
is because of something that happened on
the show we had last night um I try to
build on conversation so uh blessing
will you show them the clip of the show
last night
so I don't think it's as a woman I know
for well
uh it won't ingrain to me to hate men
but as you grow up and you see them act
a certain way then you're gonna have an
opinion of them I wouldn't go swimming I
wouldn't go swimming in Australia even
if there was one shark attack I wouldn't
go near it because I know the
consequences but yet as women we're
expected to to still
um trust men that that hurt us
what do you see that men do that's so
bad well first of all I said about the
domestic violence and then I think if
you look at like where women women do it
too midnight dying at the same rates so
well they can't who's to say what do you
mean who's to say I think everything
that we see is this is what's given to
us as fast we can't take that as gospel
do you know women have diets no suicide
no suicide is is one of the biggest
indicators of our suicide is
relationship conflict or or break up so
you know maybe it's not being logged as
domestic violence yeah but there is
definitely abuse going the other way and
and that's a significant part and more
women hit men one-sided than men hit
women one-sided I I struggle I do
struggle with this like uh on this on
the websites that I've seen that women
are arrested more for domestic violence
than men even though they suffer more
and on like when in 2010 in 2020 when a
110 women died that year because of that
the hands are Mel fifty percent of those
deaths were Overkill which was they
killed them they was there was like
brutally kidding them long before that
long after that 110 in London
in the UK that's really not a lot one
every three days you don't think that's
that's an intern for the whole year so
say from the whole year yeah from the
whole year so from then to now so say at
the percentage of deaths is that that's
got to be less than one percent yeah do
you honestly think that a woman dying
every three to four days is not a lot
I don't think it's like
um I don't think it's like a pressing
like if it's not one of the numbers
because it's not one of the number one
ways people are dying here
so like like if if we're gonna talk
about if that if that's the big issue
like then we should maybe put obesity
why is it always fat people when that
alcohol is a drug and it's so normalized
but why is the default always fat why is
the default always fat it could be
alcoholism because because that can
because the stuff that self more people
die what I think what Paul's trying to
say is more people die each year from
self-inflicted things than something
that's been inflicted on somebody else
but that makes sense yeah yeah that does
make sense but it doesn't excuse it due
to I mean so say so say when I wouldn't
excuse it it's just putting it into
context so yeah if you take if you take
a number like 110 out of a country with
like 60 million people yeah and try and
make the case because that's why well
because you're trying to generalize
something about men if you're gonna if
you're gonna make a generalization about
men I want to see is this prevalent
among men is this really common when you
said 110 I'm like well okay the UK is
very populated that doesn't sound like a
lot of people and when you put it into
context but if you put into context I
don't think it's okay I don't think you
do but then if you put it into context
the same amount of women have died this
year right so it's one in one every
three to four days so say from 2020 2021
2022 if you multiply 110 that's free for
a year that's close to a year so our
three years there was one year where a
woman was dying every day
that's mad will you put it like that I
don't I don't think it's okay but I just
if I had to guess if I had to guess I
would think that things like car crashes
and obesity would probably be higher but
they're self-inflicted so that's on them
I could walk down the street and be
murdered by a man and and what did I do
to deserve that
why does it have to be a man you could
be murdered but no but I was talking
about that statistic when we're talking
about domestic violence it's it's making
women my point my point is why would I
make a generalization about men when
it's not a huge percentage of people
that are dying oh okay so hands have
been like from domestic violence I I
well I think that's probably just the
difference in opinion because I think
one every three to four days is what two
a week off I mean you can you can
manipulate statistics to make them sound
alike it's a lot more prevalent than it
is but but when you when you look at how
many people if I Googled right now how
many people are in the UK is that 60
million yeah 60 million people in the UK
but 110 that's not that's cool but then
when you put it down to one to every
three to four days that doesn't and that
like I said about one like a year and
that would have been just women but this
is one saying but this is what I'm
saying this is why because there's a
consequence for Action so as men if
you're gonna enable other men and and
whatnot then it's a repercussion enable
other men we just saw in a clip where
when people were attacked when he was
attacking a woman in public people
rushed to her yes how was that enabling
but well the thing is I I understand
that video the video is terrible but
that's just one incident you could film
that tomorrow and and that could be a
different reaction because I personally
have seen free incidences of domestic
violence with a woman being attacked and
I haven't seen any I was the one that
went to see them it was me so I I know
full well that that happens so I'm not
shocked by that video at all because I
don't know what people expect do you
okay do you feel like it's equal like
people protect the genders equally I I
do I do see what the problem with men
but
um in terms of how they're treated in
society but a lot of it are dare to say
that the misandry is almost a bit of a
pity party like if you are someone who's
50 plus about this they ain't got a clue
what you're talking about but they've
for the last 50 years seen women go
through this this and this and they're
probably like well of course
okay
um do you guys hear a buzzing yeah
there's a little buzzing in the
headphones not in line yeah I can hear
slightly
um but what did you guys think of that
clip so I want to start with Alex
because you were there what were you
thinking yesterday
um
I would say I was I was just thinking
she's just very very Miss uh misinformed
very ignorant and you know she has this
like um she's obviously been like highly
influenced by extremist groups and so
all points were just kind of in that
line of just like I experienced I know
someone who experienced this therefore
it's an issue for society
um I didn't like how she dismissed men's
issues because I thought that was very
kind of uh she kind of threw herself
under the bus there where if you claim
you care about equality and woman's
rights and then say men's rights Miss
Andre is a pity party is kind of like
extremely
extremely ignorant so yeah
um what did you think of the club in my
opinion um I feel like she's been for a
lot of things because for her to talk
like that she has experienced a lot of
things when it comes to men so that's
why that's why I can't judge her what
she's saying and I'm saying because I I
from my experience I've been around a
lot of people when they tell me their
stories about it could be about a guy or
female but the way to go into it I
deeply listen to it so hard and I can
just tell like every guy through a lot
so for her to talk like that I can't
judge because she's she's hurting and I
can just hearing her voice she's early
tonight that's why I enjoyed in there
she looked like she wanted to cry on me
okay can I yeah go ahead I mean I'm sure
she was pretty hurt like you can
actually tell that she's gone through
some sort of rough experience however
I maybe like Alex think that she's those
kind of people that would manipulate the
information for you to take the message
the way she wants you to have it does
that make sense and that is where you
lose that you know understanding because
the statistics went from every other day
for every three days and then one year
and then three years Gina is like taking
the same issue and then molding it to
favor your point of view so that is not
fair because it has to be objective like
I don't know that's how I feel about it
but it's clearly that she's gone through
some rough experiences
um can I say something I think obviously
she just represents some of the biggest
problems that we have nowadays it's just
where people are talking without having
the capacity to be talking on the topics
they're talking about that's why she
misused statistics that's why she missed
she didn't quite make a coherent
argument however the sentiment and the
words that she's trying to say I fully
sympathize and actually kind of
agree with what she's saying yes there's
domestic violence towards men yes yes
yes yes but traditionally culturally
socially politically economically
Everything Lee women tend to kind of be
the ones on the losing side and I say
that not just for my own experience I
say that from my own research into this
I say that for my own like life
experiences you know the people how yeah
and the losing side of the topics that
she's talking about of course think
about it even in in Latin America for
example in Africa in Asia there's a lot
of women that are in the hands of men
and that even though that's outside of
Europe and the world that we live in
that's just another example of how
actually the world is somewhat like can
we stick to the West even in the west
even in the west is the same thing like
if I'm gonna I'm not gonna lie I bet you
that if I walk even let's say just
London if I walk around London and I ask
a few girls like has a man ever slapped
you a lot of them will say yes
that's not even and that's again
deserving uh to slap somewhere
somebody slap that's subjective again
most abuses is mutual meaning both
parties are hitting each other so a lot
of girls will hit guys often first and
then claim and cry abuse when he hits
back but you hit him first yeah okay and
and most so um they looked at abuse
abusive situations and the ones that are
one-sided which means one party's
hitting the other and the other is not
returning women are more likely to do
that than men okay I understand that
completely I've been in that situation
before of course I hit back because I'm
not hit to take slaps for no reason
right but it still remains like the fact
that even for and this goes to your
question should women fear men right A
man is way stronger than a woman do you
get so why are you even hidden in the
first place you shouldn't and yet they
do are more race than women do and some
yes quiet victims some of them can cause
the situation but let's not run away
from the fact that there's a lot of
women that are actually victims to the
toxic masculinity that is out there
toxic masculine go ahead Auntie [ __ ]
somebody that's been in an abusive
relationship [ __ ] what's she saying
[ __ ] as far as I'm concerned she's
going from one side
she's going from one side she's going
she's if you go onto the internet and
you look for women who have been abused
you're gonna get one set of figures what
about the men that have been abused
there's men out there that have been
abused that are being abused there was a
um I think there was a program I think I
mentioned it when I saw the shows there
was a guy and he almost lost his life
through being with his partner
how many of these how many men suffer in
silence a woman will go out there and
she will slap a man
right and if the man goes and calls the
police is the police going to come and
arrest him and take him is that going
down as a statistic and I'm not even
defending a man because as far as I'm
concerned no one deserves to get hit but
you've got to be fear about it a woman
will turn around slap a man and I'm
talking I've seen it happen I know if it
happened a woman will turn around slap a
man call the police if the man slaps
about and they will take the man how
many men out there are getting slapped
by women and that will call the police
and say this woman slapped me how many
men are going out women are too so quick
to easy and turn around and say oh I've
been abused how is it for a man if I'm F
women if that society would accept that
men get abused they will speak up more
and then you'll see the statistics
change so as far as I'm concerned all
that talk about we should fear men and
whatever I've been battered by a man I
do not fear men because that is a rare
occasion that is a rare occasion that is
rare I'm not gonna go around and say oh
because I got abused all women out there
were getting abused because I know that
men get abused out there and it's not
publicized and if there were statistics
for men I'm not defending anybody
getting abused but you've got to be fair
about it and as far as I'm concerned she
don't even look like she suffered she
looked like she's been around people
they feather this go on the internet
sometimes you need to turn off the
internet and use your brain and all
she's doing is getting her information
from the internet and from she looks
traumatized go and get counseling girl
or something like that she reminds me
and just go and by the way she looks I
don't care whether people hate me she
looks like a plain bitter feminist
lesbian nothing about her says nothing
about her I'm sorry I'm gonna say
nothing about her says feminine nothing
about her says oh this is what's going
on she just looks like she's on one
agenda and that's the way she was going
so I'm getting tired of hearing that oh
this is what happens to women I want to
hear what happens to the men because the
men out there are suffering in silence
and it's because of society that men do
not speak up men do not speak up because
they're so busy Easy Feeling fearful
that they're going to get called a beta
oh how can you let that woman slap you
or how can you let that woman stab you
up this man they're suffering but
because of society they're not saying
nothing so if they're going to turn
around and say oh what she's saying is
right oh is your fair man [ __ ]
100.
bars but I still remain it's true some
men suffer I get it but let's not why do
you always have a response I do have a
response because I've got a lot of
experience actually speaking
that's word number one and I'm here to
help you boys about get onto you don't
he's a man not a boy no he's a boy him
to say [ __ ] you too more [ __ ] this to a
woman like me that's in here
I said [ __ ] I said
and you never had that attitude towards
me no because I respect you're older
than me he's younger than me
I don't think respect it should be of
course but then the respects also comes
from the fact that you respect the fact
that somebody has been on this Earth
longer than you so they know things you
don't know so you're moving on so what
you said was rude and then secondly I
will say it's not that women should fear
men because actually I think you as a
woman you can have ways of dealing with
those situations but I'm not going to
run away from the fact that yeah men get
abused but women on the losing side on
that one I don't know how are they on
the loose I'm not gonna lie I'm so sorry
how are they on the losing side if if
women can call the police and they're
unbelieved but men can call the police
and they're not cool because the reason
why I say we're on the losing side is
because they still we're getting how
many women suffer in silence you can't
be sitting there and acting like this I
would say not many with the amount of
girls that have come on my show and and
claim to have been abused even though
they didn't seek police help right I
would say not many I would say most
girls if they suffer they tell the whole
town about it you asked me and I told
you I didn't find a report why not why
not I didn't cause I just feel like you
know why not why not make him look bad
you know make you look bad rubbish
you're saying that somebody else hit you
somebody did something bad but it's
different why do you think they're not
[ __ ] to the men who don't report the
fact that they get hit by that yeah
of course I hit him back
but at the at that point there's a
difference I hit him back that would be
self-defense and then two the way that
he hit me is nothing compared to how he
how he how I hit him and that's what the
difference is and I say each other
you're abusing each other and then wait
and then let me bring you another
another example I stayed quiet not
because I'm embarrassed but I stayed
quiet because coach really actually what
happened to me wasn't really that bad so
you just left it open for somebody else
to get abused by that same person that
abuse you because you never reports you
just assume now that you're gonna help
her a brother stop a brother from going
into prison and you're gonna help him
out it is
[ __ ] that is why for real and he
said that is why no because you're
allowed him to go out there and
traumatize somebody else I get sick and
tired of people turning around and
saying I've been abused I've been abused
I've been abused if you can stand up and
say I've been abused why don't you go
police I went police why don't you go
police why don't you file a report and
then you're going to turn around and
then you've got the audacity to turn
around and say well if that's the case
and I never reported it let the man
stand there in silence and let them and
suffer that's wrong and I'll tell you
another reason submission is another
problem why a lot of women get hit too
listen right violence has got nothing to
do with submission violence has got to
do with somebody feeling that they've
got more power over somebody else
whether it's a woman that turns around
and slaps a man in his face she feels
you know what I've got more power
because yeah I slap you and what what
are you going to do about it what is
society going to do about it nothing
let's turn down nothing don't men
usually be in the in a superior position
which means that my point just stands by
what you told me please let's break that
down yeah who are men more willing to
help help men or women
probably women because they've seen
their eyes Okay okay so even if a man is
in a superior position he's more willing
to help you right so so that argument
doesn't make sense if if your boy is
getting hit your boy will jump in and be
like stop him my boy simple they just
won't have to hit the girl and a lot of
the time the reason why they can wait if
your voice is getting a headache so if
your boy is getting hit and they'll say
stop no no guys get into fights over
this stuff can I just nice that poo
how many times has anybody seen a girl
hit a man and jumps in and said oh don't
hit him never oh I've never seen it
thank you and if you had to and have you
never seen it well there you go may I
just say something though there's a few
things I'm so sorry my love I missed
your name again
I like you but there's some things that
you're saying that make me feel very
uncomfortable because first of all it's
like okay you say that I'm sorry to take
your example you got abused you did not
report it that's one thing that
annoys me
people go to social judge social like
Society like social media to be their
judge and I always say to them first
thing go to the police that's the first
thing you're meant to do you're not
meant to go to social media and address
it the reason why the good social media
address is because Society like you said
Auntie Jenny is more acceptable or it's
more open to receive
um a complaint from a woman than a
complaint from a man and also abuse are
we talking about only physical abuse
because abuse starts also emotionally
mentally and women are very very good at
that yeah I'm a woman I can say it I
would say it we women are very good at
that so before I'm not justifying any
physical abuses no justifiable let's say
that as a disclaimer but abuse starts
before even hands get laid on and who
starts that most times women
[Music]
what also doesn't make sense to me is if
if you didn't go to the police but
you're assassinating his character on a
public platform so it doesn't really
make sense because people know who you
dated so anyone that knows you that sees
this podcast anyone that knows me knew I
went through it but I'm saying like why
are you able to assassinate his
character but you're not able to go to
the police
because now I'm over it I can talk about
it it's easy when I was going through
and this is the thing about abuse that
people don't understand it goes beyond
physical it's almost like you're under
this crazy trance it's true because a
woman like me for any anyone that knows
me you guys at home that actually do
know me if you saw the ones that did see
me like just a year ago you'll never
believe that I'm the same person because
I know actually the thing is we talk
about abuse and unless you've gone
through it you really don't understand
what it does mean and why it's so deep
and why actually some people as that
girl said are really fearful because
it's really deep I stayed stuck for five
years I couldn't leave I felt you say it
wasn't that deep
well you know she said that it was
perceived by by her culture as not that
yeah
no it was perceived yeah it was
perceived it yeah of course because I go
I try to
talk to his family even with my family
has even stopped speaking to my family
because I couldn't leave him I was still
going through the situation my family
was just so scared all the time right so
I stayed away when I approached the
family so why are you complaining like
stop you why why is he you meet him
angry
you need to like put structure this
right so so you said initially you said
it wasn't that bad but now you're saying
it wasn't that bad relative to the
culture is that what you're saying now
yeah he's relative to the culture okay
cool what is what what happened he like
punched you in the face too many things
too many things like so many many things
that I don't even need to go into
because of my body yeah everything makes
sense like it like punched me in the
face I I would go to the police but have
you heard of Stockholm syndrome oh my
God all these times listen Guys these
feminists have the craziest vocabulary
listen I'm telling you right now
emotional Stockholm syndrome
I know it's Stockholm when women fall in
love with their Captor
chapter he was your boyfriend and then
he became abusive because he abused it
from this I'll give you a little
breakdown into how it goes so you fall
in love with somebody they love bomb you
you're amazing you think it's the best
time in the world you find your prince
charming One day things start to attract
the compliments start turning into this
little criticism and then it grows and
grows and grows by the time you get hit
you're already desperately madly in love
with this person you think that you're
forever and after you commit you
dedicate by the time things get really
wrong you've already given everything
and you're thinking how am I going to
leave this situation where do I go what
happens oh my God then on top of that
I'm a woman I've been with you all this
time if I leave I'm not that much good
there's so many things that actually
Society does do actually even like allow
these situations to go on we can
complain and say that no you are alive
when you don't report it that's right
because you can't let that man leave
like you can't leave that man and tell
him I'm not gonna represent him and not
fear for the next woman that's my only
issue here do you understand and I can
appreciate the difficulty but then this
is why you think that women are on the
losing side because if he's still on at
large with no repercussions and only
just Society telling pointing the thing
and be like he's bad that's not enough
can I just say something right as far as
I'm concerned the man ain't done [ __ ] to
you the money does [ __ ] to you because
you're on a I can turn around and say
yes my son's dad was abusive I put it
down on the police records you know what
because he knows it's out there and he
knows that the police knows about it and
it's been out there we've been to court
right but as far as I'm concerned
yours never happened if I was that man
and you're here it's defamation of
character because there is nothing there
on paper to say that the man abused you
and that's what Paul was saying you're
here telling thousands of people that
this man abused you what evidence have
you got that he that he abused you okay
as far as I'm concerned you could fall
down the stairs and brush your knee and
give them scars because there's nothing
legal on paper to say that he was abused
hang in a minute let me finish he can
turn around today and he can say do you
know what defamation a character because
there's nothing there on paper and she's
there telling the air the whole world
that I'm abusive if I'm abusive where is
the record and that's the problem too
many people go out there and they all
who have been abused whether it's men or
women and they make all these
accusations in public without any proof
and as far as I'm concerned if I was a
man and I was beating on a woman and the
woman ain't got the guts enough to go to
the police and report it but she's got
guts enough to go and sit down on social
media and tell the whole world I'm gonna
go and take it out
I'm gonna go and take it up because as
far as I'm going that's defamation a
character let him come I've got plenty
of evidence
you ain't got no evidence
I called into the law because if you had
evidence the police would have had the
evidence
right now but you've never done it I
didn't do it you never I don't care why
you ain't done it because as far as I'm
concerned if you ain't done it in my
view it ain't it hasn't happened it has
not happened
on paper I definitely what I've been
living in the UK for too long what do
you mean I think that's the inside how
do you know where I live how do you know
where I live we have the same with no I
said that I was raised I was born here
and I raised and I also told you that I
go to Barbados three times a year so
where I come from has got nothing to do
and if you didn't insult me insult me
properly as far as I'm concerned you're
sitting down there and you're talking
about respecting your elders and then
you're gonna come and tell me some
[ __ ] like that well let me tell you
right it don't matter if I was abusing
Barbados I would have been reporting it
in Barbados
it's more likely that they wouldn't even
help I was done what are you talking
about don't knock it till you've tried
it you can't do you can't talk about it
I know I've tried it no you can't talk
about what you don't know you ain't
tried it because you already said you
did not report it and you can't talk
about the laws in Barbados because the
laws in Barbados are up to cue with the
laws in the west let me tell you that
the laws in the west don't work they got
them they don't work if you don't damn
well use them if you don't use you try
using them how can it work for me how
come it work for me no how can we work
for me I reported that how come it
worked for me all right now I'm gonna
ask myself that because I am not relaxed
bringing down somebody on social media
just for publicity stuff don't need
publicity that's why they're talking
about all the stats because the stats
will be all out of sync because of
people like that you can't turn around
and therefore make somebody's character
for no reason I'm not doing it for no
reason I'm doing it so that the women
that go through something and don't have
the balls to go to the police they can
actually say do you know what at least
there's somebody there that says if I
leave at least I'm free of it nah
because not everybody go to the place if
you can if you can't I understand why
you didn't and if you want to message me
I'll help you don't worry my sisters I
got you what you're going through nobody
knows until you're going through it
nobody trust me
um okay but I would also like to add a
slightly analytical perspective has any
of the viewers noticed that around these
conversations there's a there's a strong
pattern with feminists right so normally
it's everyone's being abused none of
them report it and their personal
experience counts for the reality so
it's normally like you know everyone I I
know two people who got jumped by by you
know guys on the street
um so that makes it a problem I didn't
tell him anyone at the time but I was
suffering inside I was damages in all
these ways that no one can really prove
or evidence but I will tell you I was
damaged because I guess no one can prove
it
um and you know it's an issue for
everyone well that's why boys don't
report it so domestic abuse for boys
don't exist because the police don't see
it is saying is that you can't use the
statistics when you're not contributing
to the statistics to defend what you
have not reported that's basically what
you can see I think you can't use that
to the advantage if you don't help
contribute that because you reporting it
no matter when it happens you can report
a year letter to your letters reported
help contribute to that statistic in
such a way it now shows and proves that
head you know because you know even if
they don't press charges today or
tomorrow or for your case like people
have patterns of behavior exactly and so
you're just contributing to the problem
by not reporting it like like by going
on a on a podcast using the story to
make you look good
and I don't need it and then not
reporting it and then saying that under
the guise if I'm doing this to help
women it's like if you wanted to help
women then you would have went to the
police okay they're all Noble victims
it's like I don't know like I think that
sometimes when people like talk about
these situations they haven't gone
through they really get don't get the
image for example the reason why I don't
even need to report it because a lot of
these things have happened in public I
never I I actually said withdraw the
charges I don't want him to go to prison
why because I love them and I didn't
want him to be in prison over something
that I thought me and him could actually
resolve family could be involved in help
but you're fighting a law against
against a lot of factors that's why I
say if you're going to use the argument
of Vlog or you're here talking about it
reading reports it didn't happen then
men don't get abused and it's the the
point Still Remains women get abused
more than men that's like as simple as
that and that's why I'm saying like that
because men don't report it don't happen
no women one-sided abuse is more common
for women to do so if if you're not if
it's not mutual hitting
okay because like I I wouldn't say
that's an abusive relationship if you
guys are hitting each other like I would
I wouldn't say you're a victim each
other you're just toxic yeah it's just
and so like I would argue you're not a
victim if you're hitting each other
constantly this this reminds me of the
theory of a Hysteria
if you read like The victorians used to
talk about this this is this is like
you know quite controversial but the
victorians had this idea that um of the
hysteria that sometimes women would get
into Hyster about things and and like
just make stuff up and a lot of the time
when I talk to the feminists I mean
outside I do get the vibe that like she
might be because because there's people
that they all say the same thing it's
like apparently everyone's been abused
doesn't matter whether they go to top
you any other or the worst you need
everyone's abused especially when
there's a big media event all of a
sudden everyone comes out and they've
had the same story and I'm like really
like because because Amber Heard got
punched in the face now you were getting
whooped yesterday really I've known you
for like three years you know and I just
it just shows a lack of accountability
like when you ask them these questions
they start throwing out all these words
well it's because like it goes back to
if you really cared about women you'd
report it if you if you genuinely like
because you can report it you can report
it later and you might not win but at
least it goes on record and police can
pull up those records to use in a case
later cool like I said so any records
that need to be used will be used the
reason why I would prefer to use this
platform to speak about and to do that
is because like I said I don't only just
Champion women and men and sometimes men
today I meant to be on The Voice side
and I also championed the black
community culturally there's certain
things that I decided not to do because
I I have a complete a complex makeup so
I'd rather sit here and tell girls if
you're being abused and you don't know
what to do and you're lost and you feel
like your world is so lonely and nobody
can help you I'm telling you can get out
of it you don't if you don't feel like
we're reporting to the police don't go
speak to somebody somebody will
understand because people have gone
through and they've come out of it
stronger than whatever the situation
they were in so that's all I'm saying
abuse exists it's real is very very deep
and that's why people sometimes don't
talk about it the same way it goes for
men same way it goes for women but let's
not try and act like women don't
actually go through this and a lot of
the time like you said women will then
say Oh yeah I was abused as well yeah
because a lot of people go through
things and they hide it they embarrassed
or they they feel ashamed or especially
when you're not talking about oh yeah
but you're damaged goods you know things
like that people won't speak up that's
what it is listen right you can go if
you're abused and you can report it and
nobody will know about it
nobody would know a bay they've even got
special codes now that you can go into a
shop and you can say to them you know
give them a keyword I can't remember
what the name is it's a woman's name yes
I need to call Angela or even in the
evening any shops or chemists or you
know I mean some pharmacies where is
that for men so it's not to say that oh
you're gonna be ashamed listen right if
anybody's out there getting abused
Ripple it don't go and talk to your
friends about it Go and report it
there's nothing to be ashamed about
nobody needs to know don't go out there
and advertise it go and talk to somebody
about it that's what you need to do I am
Champion for the women it's nothing to
do with culture it's nothing to the
Blackness it's to do with women and men
full stop if you are getting abused go
and report it don't talk to your friends
about it as soon as it happens go and
report it because there is help for you
and I would like them to be codes for
men too and they should be coats for men
so that every man is getting abused
rather than going somewhere and you
think to yourself well I'm a man and I
have to go and report this they should
be a cold where a man goes into a police
station said the code and then he gets
treated the same way as if a woman says
the code I hear you anti but um you get
some people out there that they just
won't go to the police either because um
they feel like a piece ain't gonna do
nothing about it you know what I'm
saying don't knock it till you've tried
it I hear you but um this is I'm just
saying in general there's a lot of
people you can't say that to everyone if
you've been abused go report it to the
police because not everybody's gonna do
that some people don't even trust the
police that some people might have like
oh maybe you say for example oh yeah
please killed my son or you know I mean
they don't trust the police so
everybody's not going to go to the
police I understand I understand what
you're saying but if they're not going
to report it
and you don't want to say nothing about
it shut up about it don't go on social
media and advertise it I agree shut up
about it because I don't understand how
somebody could be too scared too
frightened to report it to a police but
they're not too scared too frightened to
go on a public platform and talk about
it it don't make no sense it don't make
no sense to me do you know what it is
right you get some people right they
feel like if they announce you on the
social media they feel that they're
releasing their stress you know what I'm
saying that is from my experience I've
seen this you know I'm saying in this
generation right now back in the days
right now I've seen a lot of people when
they're going through this that they
feel like if they go on social media
going to live and then Express their
feelings because they just want the
world to know what they're going for
yeah but there's there's therapists I
hate it but a lot of people don't do
that friends and family like why are you
going to on a pot like if if you're
saying you're afraid if you're afraid of
not being believed if that's that's what
you're saying then you're gonna go talk
to more people about it that doesn't
like two plus two doesn't
yeah but like why do you I don't believe
it yeah I don't buy I I think it's a
form of social currency now have you
been abused
yeah oh how was it did you report it no
because then don't say you've been
abused then same as me sorry no that's
that's not how that works so so you
don't use your your experiences as a way
to kind of prove a point but that
doesn't mean you can't factually state
that like you ask the question so I'm
gonna answer your questions factually
anyway moving on
um yeah I think it's a form of social
currency I think because we've seen we
see this a lot right whether they'll
come up here and they've all you know
everyone's got their victims during
their Noble victims like I just feel
like they get a kick off it like it's
it's cool to be like
to be one of the downtrodden is called
to be a victim sorry I wouldn't say it's
it's like
cool to be a victim
I went through it and I think maybe
time has passed like you said
you you are now you are now able to vent
about what happened but maybe when
you're going through that and I'll say
someone who did go through that in two
relationships
there was no way I could speak about it
because to me no one would believe me
to me I just had a baby with him and
you know you you've given this this guy
a son and it made your bed light and to
society especially to like Latin
American cultures Portuguese okay
uh you have to you have to like even
though as stupid as it sound okay you've
had a child with someone okay make it
look like you're doing well in life so
you don't want to come out and say you
know what I am being abused I am being
mentally uh being abused I have to say
mentally because it wasn't physical with
this one right
um so what happened the second time can
I so happened a second time uh the
second time was um it became physical
but with this one
it was both so I have to say that I was
also I got I also got physical with him
and there was a time that there was a
time the time I had bited him so hard in
the mouth and he had a bus lick for a
whole week did he call the police on you
no no he didn't because he he would
always say I'll never call the police on
you because that's not me I'm a man and
I'll take it and in my and in my head
Auntie Jenny I was like I'm I'm a piece
of [ __ ] because even though he's tall
and he's bigger than me I still hit him
and I have no right to do that so I am
abusing him even though he did that so
it was just like you say it was it was
it was an absolutely toxic relationship
but now when I look back at it I'm like
I I don't blame him I don't see him any
I don't see him any less because I was
just as bad as him like we were just as
we were just as bad as each other I
respect that you can admit that idea
yeah yeah I think it's definitely a lot
of um strength it takes to come and kind
of own up to your part in negative
experiences I've noticed a lot of people
who say these kind of things have this
idea that like they're never they never
had anything to do with it right I
couldn't have solved my own problem for
this that this that this that but they
can come out and tell the whole world
about it but when you ask them what did
you do in the time I know people who are
like staunch feminists and they're still
dating guys and being abused and telling
me about like it's some like Oh I'm a
victim I was like oh you've been reading
all these like Margaret Atwood book for
time you still didn't know when you were
being punched in the face that you
should maybe leave and you can't you
can't like you can't just be like all
right I'll hold the L you know I stayed
in a bad situation too long I should
have moved but you rarely get that it's
normally everyone else's fault so I
respect I respect your admittance thank
you accountability is important in a
relationship I guess everyone looking at
of course it's who does more than the
other well accountability is important I
guess you have to say right I'm
listening to you the young lady in the
middle loose Lucy Lucia loose
have you had any counseling or anything
like that for what you've been through
with my first relationship no the whole
thing because as far as I'm concerned
I'm looking at you and it's still raw
I have to say I have to say I am a I am
like a feisty little something
um but yes I have have had counseling
and I'm still having it okay on on my
anger and my um and my explosiveness
which has calmed down a lot
um but do you mean a lot of relationship
wise oh yeah I'm just glad that you're
getting some kind of help via a hands up
for that I like I like that because you
can tell in your face that the way
you're talking about it like it happened
yesterday and it still has that same
effect on you that's why I just thought
you look you look traumatized oh wow I
didn't see that at all but yeah don't
forget I've been abused I've been abused
as well and I can see why when she was
talking it was like she was reliving it
it was like me mine's all gone do you
know what I mean I just cut that way a
long time ago got rid of it had
counseling sorted it out but for her to
me it was raw I expected it to start
crying like to relive it all over again
that's what I picked up from her that's
why I asked and the fact that it's still
ongoing council is the one going I got
listen I'm not that good well damn the
facts of people's heads so maybe that's
it you're right no I I am taking I am
still taking counseling like in the
relationship I am now it's very healthy
though there are some things that that
don't go right you know my the partner I
have now he's like very smart and he
tries to like outsmart me sometimes and
I don't want him to outsmart me but I
recognize that he is smarter than me so
we have like we we Clash sometimes
um so for that reason I do take
counseling but the counseling I have
taken before has absolutely helped me
control my anger because I would be one
that if someone was beeping at me in the
car I would come out like and punch them
that would be on one whereas now whereas
now Colombiana yeah whereas now I I am
not that person like let's say road rage
has calmed down but I I can't say that
I'm perfect no yes yes I do take
counseling and and I love it yeah and he
he the other day he was like his his 80
pound for your counseling like of
Colombian lady back home and then he
he's like I support that because we are
going to do anything that that means for
our relationship to be healthy we do we
have to invest and put some money down
hey ho why not but I'm I'm all for that
I'm not going to say okay I took some
counsel and I'm fine I'm no like yeah I
have a question
so you said like you're the kind of
person that something happens the road
you get out of your car and you're ready
to get into a notification right yeah I
literally I did yeah do you think that
played any part in like your past
relationships because I could imagine at
one point that would that would affect
of course because even though you're in
a relationship it gets to a point where
when you're arguing with him you forget
he's your boyfriend and the way you're
seeing it is oh you're screwing up to me
so I'm going to square up to you this
relationship and nothing goes out the
window uh he's trying to prove a point
but no this is the point that I think
um so so yeah absolutely it absolutely
does go out the window and then all this
the way I was brought up like in school
I was in a school where I like
loads of fights went on and and I was
always involved I got bullied in like
yeah seven year eight and then in year
nine I was like you know this is not
happening and then I became I just like
um develop like this Shield I'm gonna
say and then of course I I reflect that
in my relationships but so with the baby
dad
it was horrible it was like that then
with the next partner I had he was he
was lovely I'm not gonna say he wasn't
but that there was physical violence
involved the memory both from both from
both so in the relationship I am now
that doesn't happen and here I am I'm
like okay
any therapy and I'm taking it and you
know this I'm going to do my absolute
best on whatever it takes to make this
one work why because I have a man that
sees me the same way he knows my past he
knows all the madness he even knows I've
got a criminal record he knows that and
he's a record yeah and he accepts me and
he accepts me for that and he's like you
know I'm going to work with you because
I believe that that you can be this good
person and he knows that that deep down
I am and I and I you know I just want
the best for both of us so all this all
this BS that went on in the past
relationships I'm like okay that that
that and that that's not happening again
you're showing that
do you feel like because you're a woman
um when it comes to like physical abuse
that you get away with it more 100 100
and we [ __ ] we [ __ ] test men respect 100
we do that because I'm I'm I consider
myself a very feminine woman
so if I have a guy that gets into a
relationship with me
I need to know you are that man that's
gonna like hold me down because we do
need that we do need that um
sure yeah we we do need that I'm gonna
hold you down uh you're too feisty let
me hold you down girl because you ain't
going nowhere you know every now and
then I'm going to tell you what's what
and we like that but when we get a guy
that doesn't do that let me [ __ ] test
you and if one once twice three times
and then we just take you guys
I'm not going to say for granted but we
we [ __ ] about with you you know
I think I like I like what you're saying
because I think it shows that like you
you're aware of being a fraud person and
it's a it's a it's a way of speaking I I
almost never I'm generally shocked you
say a fraud person yeah like like you're
you're flawed like you're you know
you're cool with saying listen I can be
very physically kind of domineering I
can be aggressive if you notice when you
hear people talk about these kind of
women talk about these kind they never
say anything that you know anything is
on their part then
the idea is that they're perfect
not you but I'm saying like in general
it's always that the man's the bad guy
they're the victim can I can I just
answer the question before your
experiences
has it made you fear men
has it made me Fair men yeah do you fear
men no okay she's aggressively I don't I
don't feel me
he gave me a different type of
confidence and it's the thing where
I know that if I know that if I'm going
to fight a man he will he will [ __ ] me
up
but I'm still gonna give you my all you
know
yeah thank you but I know that
biologically I can't take on a man if I
was to go and find my boyfriend he he'll
pin me down and box me and knock me out
but I and I'm kind of thankful for that
because I now I don't like I don't see
myself being like like a little squirrel
and scared to speak no I don't see
myself doing that so I know in a way
it's good but sometimes I go overboard
and then I just take it too far and then
you know like all these problems I've
had in the past
okay that is good can I just say
something I also don't fear men because
of my situation because I feel like when
you when you've already gone through so
much like crazy stuff you look at it now
and you've gone over it and you're now
it's normal it's nothing so like I said
I wouldn't girls you don't need to fear
men obviously they are physically more
they're stronger than you but what I
always say is if someone if a man was
coming coming to hit me I wouldn't even
hit him back to show him like I want to
hit you back if he hits me I'll just use
my my fluidity to fall a little bit more
and find ways to squirrel my way out of
it it's just don't be afraid just be
smart I fear women more than I fear man
me too I I think women are much scarier
yeah man absolutely that's why I wish
I'm crazy no you're not crazy I do I do
I do Street interviews all the time I've
only been I'm like attacked or like had
someone try to attack me and it's always
been a woman oh wow yeah like I had a
girl they were like holding her back she
was trying to she was trying to throw a
punch at me and like they were holding
her back so she wouldn't yeah she
knocked the mic on my out of my hand
what did you say to her did you report
her no they took it down off of YouTube
somehow she got it taken down but it's
on Jessie praise's Channel going what
did you tell her did you report it sorry
that you experienced that but what did
you do well wow so well she sucks so
okay okay this would happen I was I was
doing Street interviews and basically
like what what set her off was we were
talking about
how you're not entitled to safety and I
feel like as women like
it it's not smart to walk they always
use the example like well I can't walk
home alone at night and I'm like well
neither can men like why are you walking
home alone at night that sounds like a
stupid idea
on a dark alley yeah
a dude either and so I just said like
why are you entitled to security and
safety like no one's ever had security
and safety in all of history ever but
you deserve it why and it'd be nice it'd
be it'd be a perk but like you want to
live in a big city that you chose to
anyway so this is why she got mad and so
then she's like you effing slag and I
didn't know what slag meant oh I didn't
know what that meant but I knew I was
being insulted
I'll have you use slag and like yeah and
then she like knocks the mic out of my
hand she's coming at me my friend
Jesse's like pulling her away so because
I brought a guy so like you know it's
mine yeah and
um yeah I did you know I called her a
whale but like what I said was a fact
she was a world okay yeah I mean like
let's see what's the heavyweight the
drunk came well she was she was drunk as
well
it was like at night
but I'm like then that's that's where
the whales started yeah imagine the boys
fighting a lot of some girl on girl boy
on boy I feel like the people feel like
it's okay because it's same same agenda
so it's not as bad yeah that's why sport
is divided in Sexes yeah I don't think
that's it's not good yeah that's funny
but why like okay if you went up to
Dwayne The Rock Johnson and you started
something with him and you got hit back
no one would really feel bad for you
yeah why do we feel bad for women if you
hit him and you start something and you
get hit back you started it yeah whoever
started it you started it that's your
blame absolutely yeah
you never meant he first mom taught me
that in school never he first believed
that he you hit double yes
but never never hit first obviously yeah
I've always followed the policy of
equality so uh if a woman hits me then
you've just signed a consent form to be
hit back
that's how my son was raised yeah I have
I have no kind of I don't believe
equality in that I'm I'm curious from
the men from your experience do you
think men are abused more or women are
abused more just from personal
experience not social media not like
just from people you know personally
that you would believe and trust in my
opinion um I think it's 50 50 you know
what I'm saying icon to say yeah woman
abuse more okay any ladies there's a lot
of men out there don't say nothing so I
say 50 50 you know what I'm saying uh I
would say well let's put it this way I
know about three or four men who've been
you know supposedly been abused and some
one one or two of them was really really
bad and I've known a couple of I've
known like one of the girls I saw seeing
like six months ago was really badly
abused like was anorexic because of it
XYZ
um personally I I view it more as like a
character like you have to be a certain
kind of person it's always it's always
people who just like have have
like they get into relationships too
young they build their personality by
being co-dependent on someone else it's
always those kind of the guys who get
abused are very like low-key emotional
dudes because they'll be telling us to
be like bro you're like six two bro like
what are you like why can't like you
know and he's like no I've got some deep
feeling so it's a certain kind of person
in my experience I haven't thought about
it in terms of like gender I think don't
you think it's like
oh I'm sorry
because they're man them it doesn't mean
they they don't go into a relationship
and they fall in love and you know all
this happens but I think
it's so hard to say who's who's more
because the men don't speak up like
we're like we're speaking here that's
the name part as well you know they
don't speak up because they don't want
that sometimes they're even afraid to
say okay babe I love you bye they're
afraid to say I love you but to their
girlfriends so imagine speaking about oh
she she hits me at home she scratches my
face she tears up my clothes you know
something but do you know what it is I
know something right it all depends
because
f a man
slapped a woman straight away that's
abuse
right but how many women out there and
they're slapping the men regularly but
nobody's seen it as abuse but if it was
the other way around because I'm sure
that somewhere everybody knows someone
who like I want to say oh you know I
snapped him in his face he was sworn out
slapped him in his face oh I waxed him
around the head or it's always something
just like it's nothing when it comes to
men but if but only because maybe
because she's a woman and it's weak so
the way it sounds like oh I just slapped
him but if it was a man now saying oh I
just slapped her because he's a man and
everyone's thinking about the force
behind it and I and I believe that when
it comes to abuse there's more men out
there being abused but because they
might say oh it's a slap or she's on her
period or you know what I mean oh she's
got trauma they don't they don't ever
report it because they just seen it as a
slap I think ever ever a man just gives
a woman a slap now
because of the slap on the sides of his
hand I don't know because of the
strength everybody's going to see as
some major abuse I think I think men
don't my honest opinions I think from my
experience people have seen in this
situation men don't report it because
and you can hate me if you want for
saying this they know it's weaken it
like like you you fully know that this
is pathetic in it like you're literally
getting abused by some by some five foot
two Latino thing and and you you caught
feelings you caught feeling so deep that
you can't leave and now you're really
hurt and then six months you're gonna be
pushing the edgy Facebook post about you
know love and whatever listen they know
it's weak and that's why they don't
really come up people just which is why
I say I think it's a character thing the
dollies I know who have this experience
they're always like the wettest like
it's like you can see it I've had guys
say to me like um oh you know I'm in an
abusive relationship but I can't leave I
just like I can't override my emotions
my dad's the same you know sometimes the
women in our families and our genes like
they just push it too far but you know
the man in our family just like we just
can't leave we just fall really deeply
in love and XYZ I looked at him I felt
really sorry for him because he was he
was a good looking guy who's from like
Yorkshire somewhere like that some
Village and you know I kind of got it
but it's a character in it and these the
people who haven't learned emotional
resilience the people who haven't
learned Independence and they just they
just give up any any kind of semblance
of self-respect you know and and decide
that I'm not even gonna fight that but
I'll just follow my feelings let me see
me it's everywhere around it's not the
it's not weak men
it's a strong man
that the women are like you know I want
to slap in the men like you know what if
I if I slap her back I want to knock her
the hell out so I'm just gonna walk away
from you do you know what I mean and I
don't see any to me it's never it's
never been a a weak man it's always been
a strong a strong man and that got
slapped but if the woman's having an
argue and the Mango's like I'm not a man
to look at the woman and say you know
what it depends on what happens if I if
I slap you back now
I'm gonna put myself in prison and I'm
gonna put you in hospitals you know what
I'm going to do I'm gonna go for a walk
and I know men that do that I also know
a man who the woman slapped him
so he's [ __ ] slapped her back and he
spent the night in the police station
yeah I I I it depends on what you mean
by strong I've noticed it's mostly that
the kind of woman who do that tend to
Target a certain kind of guy like they
can they can tell who the wet guy is
gonna catch feelings hard is going to be
in it because there's some Amanda I'm
like it never happens to people like me
it's not even close because it's not
even like something like even possible
but there's it's the that's why I said
the guys who deal with this they always
and they deal with it multiple times
it's always like you go from this
serious relationship and then this other
girls now really mean oh that's
different yeah that's different I'm
different
though like it's never just like one
girl and then that was it yeah
well he's got issues the same thing if
it was a woman and it got ripped do you
guys think
um that if a man
um is being abused and ends up
committing suicide over it do you think
that the woman is responsible and should
be held responsible in court 100 on
Netflix we only reported it exactly
because now is now how do you hold the
woman accountable for that that's just
the issue
if he dies before he reported it like
say like she slapped him or she was she
was hurting him and then she stabbed him
and went for an artery so it's obvious
that she killed him that way well yeah
sewer but if it was something like she
kept on abusing him and then he killed
himself but he never reported it I would
say the same thing for a woman it's sad
but if you reported it if you did report
it it's just gonna go down as you commit
suicide no but it's easier for society
to go investigate the man than the woman
that's what that's what I'm saying 100
so let's take do you guys remember when
that only fans model killed her
boyfriend yes remember from Florida the
one in the elevator that he was beating
him yeah the Nigerian guy yeah hey
blessing can you Google
um the only fans model Florida Google
um elevator footage and see if you can
find it I want to show you guys and that
is what Auntie's talking about I don't
know anything about it
you will see it in the video so I'll
tell you basically
um there was a guy that was dating
um he was a very good looking Rich
um Nigerian guy I think he's Nigerian
yes um dating an only fans model she was
blonde she's very pretty
um and basically it came out that like
the couple was arguing a lot and in the
the building like there were times when
he had been sleeping in the hallway and
he He Turned Up Dead basically she
called the cops and he had been stabbed
I want to say
yeah and
um she actually didn't even get arrested
or even though there were multiple
people that said that she had been
abusing him and she actually was out
partying like a day later she was seen
at a bar she's been out of jail for
months I think their pressing charges
now and I think she's in jail now but
she she was literally out and about for
months
isn't that no the the police I wanted to
say so I'd expect something if there's
witnesses that are willing to stand up
and say yeah this happened then yeah
they should do well yeah so let me put
it on the yeah put it on the screen he
was Nigerian he was Nigerian and she was
hitting him and he's that sense of
entitlements
but then this is where we black women
now cannot feel for you because we say
look at what you can't pick do you
understand like unfortunately I'm so
sorry because then you don't if they
don't value you know what right strong
women get abused weak women get abused
everybody because it shows strong men
get abused
because and but the way you sounded just
now
if I was a man and I heard the way you
saying that was a big tool Nigerian man
getting abused I won't say nothing
because the way that you said about him
being a bit like it was all right until
you find out he was Nigerian he had
money and he was six foot whatever tall
and then all of a sudden you changed
yeah because because
I said but if I said Effie was five foot
tall right a regular nine to five man
would you have that same impression no
you would have said he was weak but he's
Nigerian and they're not supposed to do
this extra weeks I also think that if if
she wasn't I'm sorry I think if she was
on Caucasian he wouldn't have taken it
exactly
because in America if now she reports
him he's screwed he is screwed
and I I understood from sources that he
also tried to leave her he wouldn't she
wouldn't let him leave her so probably
that's how it happened what do you mean
how can she stop him from leaving her
because because watch the video and I'll
tell you hmm
I've never heard of this
wow
wow
he doesn't want to hurt her
he doesn't
Oh that's upsane oh
you should have given one slap to reset
her brain literally that's the only time
but he's probably restarting his
boundaries right now
what does she kill him does she kill him
in the elevator no no
evidence
this is actually let me Google it that
evidence came out listen honey I get
triggered by being punched like that's
my boundary please respect my boundary
oh sorry no no I said I understand but
this is where now circumstantial factors
come come in you understand he's the
Nigerian guy he's in America black lives
matter why she's he's dating a Caucasian
woman he he knows that if he hits her
back he's gonna get down for it you
understand that is where now the old
circumstantial uh things happen but
she's the one abusing himself because
because she thought she was like you
cannot hit me you understand that's what
she's going with she's like you cannot
hit me you can do nothing to me and I'll
even call police on top of you on top of
that you understand that's what she's
thinking there when I saw that all I was
thinking is to all the men out there
that being beat by women if there's a
camera not cut the hell out because I if
he knew that there was a camera there
and after all that resisting one bit
slap and she would have been down and as
far as I'm concerned it's all on camera
so I can understand now why people would
do things in front of cameras why they
want cameras out to protect themselves
because as far as I'm concerned if
you're getting abused and you're worried
about how it's going to seek because
there's enough cameras I know it's
America but in the UK everywhere you go
you're covered to buy a camera you can't
go nowhere that cover so as far as I'm
gonna say if somebody slaps you and it's
on the camera slap her back but make
sure you give it hard so when you slap
her
break her neck or drop her on the floor
I I would say this goes back to the
equity not equality like I said I would
say the same way that goes for guns to
me goes for a man if that is happening
what you do you get up and you leave as
a man you're strong enough to either
restrain her or to run away from her
because you love me
just say like this when it's done you
run not fast I swear to God if my
brother was being hit like that from a
bit I swear to God knock that [ __ ] out
I swear to Jesus and it hits you just
run or just constrain you can have the
hands like this
you shouldn't hit first you're not a
child you're a grown woman
because one hit from a man can knock
around she'll die no but why does he
have to be considered for her
opportunity and this is what I said
Equity like a man this is let's not
forget the fact that a man is way way
physically stronger than him that's why
women exposure wait wait wait wait
listen listen I get that I get that but
this is what I'm just about to say if
that is the case I think it's incredibly
extremely irresponsible to tell somebody
to do something like hit her back yeah
because hey hey I did not say hit her
back I said knock that [ __ ] out
let me tell you
I'll tell you an example I'll tell you
an example she knows what she said no no
I'll give you an example yeah
um
this has happened to like a couple of
guys that I know where they get into a
fight
and then they knock the guy this is
knocking a guy out that's why I've been
in fact so it's more conditioned for
these things he knocks him out and
actually he gave him a brain hemorrhage
and he died the guy that he punched no
I'm gonna tell you if you're telling
somebody to knock her out somebody
there's already not even conditioned to
fight she's only fighting you because
she feels like she can because you're
supposed to [ __ ] listen do not knock
people out what you do it's not it's not
you don't it doesn't mean that first
what if that first punch knock me out
what if that first one give me a
concussion which one if she was the man
if I'm The Man I'm The Woman the one man
okay Lucio the man I now hit you because
ah you can't hit me bam what if that
first hit give you a concussion give all
right concussion cool so why does he
only have to count for me because oh if
he Nicks me back no bro you're here so
what you wanted to land only because you
didn't land there as hard enough that's
your business you wanted to land it you
didn't land well you landed it so for me
who hit first don't hit first be
expected to hit back because it's
distinct when someone comes for you what
do you say I'll come for you back I'll
come for you back when London everybody
does that you're gonna go from the back
so yeah Nigerians understand this
intrinsically
so don't beat anybody you cannot be if
you cannot fight them don't fight in the
first place you're not your size don't
go step outside
why do we why do we always take away the
consequence for women like why do we
like because this is what you're doing
you're saying the normal consequence if
you if girl girl boy boy is if you hit
someone even if they're stronger than
you you will get hit back you will
probably be knocked out but when it's
boy girl for some reason we get a a pass
why it's the same way that you wouldn't
put a woman and a man in a boxing ring
the sports are segregated
but if the woman signed up if the woman
said put me in this boxing ring I would
let her go if she said if she said I am
signing up volunteering to go box let
the [ __ ] go if she if she's playing
boxes okay dude you get hit back I'll
give you I'll give you another example
because what we saw no more examples let
me tell you what you saw was was
shocking if you want you can go and
search for a lot of these like NFL
players and baseball players and a lot
of these men that have abused their
women left for instance and see what
abuse from a man looks like okay what
are the strength levels are totally
different that's right no stop it my
love what what about those couples that
the woman is bigger than the man
the man likes big women it's fine she
likes them small it's fine she's strong
thank you and she feels like she can
drag him like he's one of her kids and I
say the same thing that I said boys if
you're strong restrainer and then walk
away girls or boys if you're not
stronger bloody protect yourself and run
from the situation
when the woman was hitting the man
you didn't say oh
why is it that if he has to hit her back
he has to restrain her why can't she
restrain herself why is it the man why
is why is he gonna take her slap but she
can't take his slap I don't care whether
this snap's bigger no that's what I'm
saying listen right I had when my son
was growing up in the neighborhood
everybody would raise their children do
not hit girls there was a particular
girl that used to go around
and pray on the boys friends of them she
will always hit them and I remember
coming home one day and there was a big
crowd outside where I lived
and I said what's going on and I can see
everybody rushing out oh it's your son
it's your son it's your son he's
fighting a girl and I thought my son
fighting a girl ran downstairs like a
mad woman run downstairs I was like hang
on a minute start pulling off people off
my son pulling them off I said and who
who first
they said she hit him I said anybody
touched my son
I'm gonna break your arms I said I
because oh but Auntie Jen he's hitting a
girl I said you already told me that she
hit him first listen right I said Son go
get her he chase her all in somebody's
ass and the mother the woman in the
house said oh but Jennifer she's a girl
I said really did she eat your son no
Move Yourself she hit my son my son
turned around and the slap that she gave
him he gave her one
my son does kickboxing I didn't give a
[ __ ] one slap to five of us and you know
something when the boys come and say but
aren't June Aunt Jane I wanna educated
him do you know what next time I saw
that girl
she had some um she had plaster on her
foot
she messed with the wrong boys and the
boys from then on she never ever hit
another boy again you know why because
Sheila then that
it changed now you hit somebody they're
gonna hit you back
[Music]
and that goes everywhere because after
that she tried taking me on
she hit me she's just amazing look at me
you know something right please
came for me right police came for me no
I didn't hear her tell a lie because she
was bigger than me she had my hands and
I head butted her and she dropped that's
what she thought she could probably said
to me um
um what happened I said well think about
it why didn't I slap her because she's
bigger look at the size of her to me and
my head but I know what happened her mom
turned around and said whatever Auntie
Jenny does to my daughter
I agree with her I stand by her
where were these kids that are bigger
than you how about you this was in this
was in East time I knew him I don't
believe I think you live in harlemen
yeah
they know me as Auntie Jenny there and I
can't back up anything I say anything I
say because everybody knows Beverly can
you can you bring that girl back on a
show if you're out there Beverly
you're out there Beverly let me know
take a second to read super chats um
again don't shoot the Messengers
um okay guys um thank you so much for
the super chats as you know we're trying
to say for an 8K camera so make sure you
hit the Super Chat button all donations
even small donations help you know it
really helps us with the studio updates
um on top of that guys make sure you
like the video um there's over 2 500 of
you in here watching live so let's get
to at least a thousand likes I really
think we should get to 2 000 a like is
free you don't have to donate anything
to just like the video it is the number
one metric that YouTube uses to push out
these streams
um for the purpose of today just because
there are a lot of super chats we are
going to stay 10 or more
um sorry we just we can't get through
all of them the super chats just start
to get really long so we're gonna do ten
dollars or more okay
um John the Baptist stay in your lane as
a woman John the Baptist the lady in the
blue doesn't want her man to hit her
back stay in your lane in if you place
as a woman
um Pearl 10 seconds after I tried to
send you
one star star I got a call on my cell
learn
the best way to deal with Hypocrites is
with the the best way to deal with
Hypocrites within the gender is for the
majority to openly call them out our
sons and daughters will inherit their
view the views we leave them the arm
star the Armstrong fill and Clan 150
Super Chat
[Music]
I'm sending this in hopes of seeing a
video of The dietitian introducing Pearl
to different foods we're gonna have to
do a special edition I'm gonna try what
is it called okra okra soup
um girl in this in the stripe blue girl
in the look at the girl in the Striped
black she is an example of maturity
responsibility and being self-aware of
her actions and making the necessary
changes to her character
Pajero a mardastic there's a huge
difference between a woman who
challenges a man versus a woman who
encourages a man it's both feminine
energy see sir Dak the abusers of my
daughters had a prior record just saying
um it's not the man's job to hold a
grown women accountable your parents
should have made you accountable stop
asking men to hold you down
um
Drew beats the moment a woman realizes
you're not the type of man to abuse her
that same woman will start emotionally
abusing the man men get emotionally
abused on a huge scale equal to woman's
physical abuse John the Baptist I am a
victim my ears have been graped with
excuse and people who refuse to be
accountable for poor Behavior another
100 Super Chat
um worst counselor to a girl ever modern
women I paid over fifty thousand dollars
to get my oldest a male therapist years
in court she's been with him for two
years she loves his guidance
um John Green I want to say that I love
Auntie and protect Pearl at all costs
any more women like both of y'all see
third act the next um lesbian-born
manufactured since birth Kenny Stacks he
should have spent that fake chain money
on braces Jason argon that's like my car
needing to be fixed but I go online and
tell everyone my car is broken and I
still don't want to fix it why would I
go online I'll just fix it
um numbers guys zero if we were
neighbors and my flat was robbed the
night after yours was robbed and I found
out you didn't call the cops you're a
low quality human period T interesting
how everyone wants to go to heaven but
nobody wants to die every choice you
make has consequences understand it
reflect it adapt it love to this channel
um see cert act Pearl is the F and Joan
of Arc for the 21st century I will show
you your work to my three daughters keep
fighting Joan you see it
um see sirach again Pearl
hey hey you got
um I don't know what you're trying to
spell here Pearl a-a-o-g
um then you put an at sign is stealing
from you you're close Pua
um Mr Freeze didn't the girl in the blue
just talk about respecting Elders she
keeps cutting off Auntie lives in a
non-existent world OJ didn't do it get
him Auntie Doug MPA the blue Power
Ranger is gonna make the whole show
about her just like last time Pearl
please don't let her hold the whole
whole show hostage again art pain there
is no such thing as toxic masculinity
there are toxic people men and women
it's a character issue I wrote a piece
on it Pearl I would love for you to read
it men get emotional emotional and
physical abused all the time and men
will never say anything because most of
the time other people will never believe
us or tell us to put up with it
um numbers guy the idea that women were
ever at the bottom of society is
complete BS children have always been at
the bottom of society until the
government inverted then men took the
the Baton he even in eastern cultures
and then that's all of the Super Chat so
guys make sure you like the video I want
to see how many likes but we're at 958
likes okay we we got to get to a
thousand likes like this is a like is
free I am so tired of y'all I see the
analytics and it's over half of you that
watch you're not even subscribed
and you know I can get over and not
subscribe but you should at least hit
the like button it takes you two seconds
just hit it hit it right now okay
um so
my next video I'm gonna have us react to
is
um another narrative that I see common
commonly in society
and this was by a conservative pundit
and political commentator who does do
any of you guys know who Tommy Lauren is
oh no let me show us shut up you don't
know Tommy Lauren the woman the the fox
the blonde yeah the blind but she's a
blonde um lady who works for Fox News
um so recently she has had a new
narrative about men and it's interesting
because girls seem to switch
um to really like
they they view men in a positive light
until the age of about 30 when their
standards get higher
and so let's just let's just play the
clip blessing
you know because I was on your podcast
talking about my little PSA to men where
people say I was trashing men there's a
big difference Andrew Tate actually
trashes women I don't trash men i trash
men that I think are soft that I think
are pathetic that I think are little
boys and I think that there is an
epidemic I will call it a pandemic the
real pandemic is soft men in this
country and I know that you agree with
me in a lot of ways but I'll tell you
this there are so many women out there
who are successful who can't find
anybody out there because a successful
men want the 25 year olds who just want
to be on Instagram and post their purses
and their yachts and this and that so I
think we have a scarcity of real men and
I don't know how we change that we start
spanking kids again we start holding
people accountable we start letting
people lose we start like taking away
the first place trophies from everybody
on the team
you know we go back to the old
Traditional Values where you know you
you raise the man
I don't even know if that would solve it
though at this point it would if
everyone did it Society has gotten so
entitled and everybody is such a victim
and all you know it's when they say the
meek will inherit the earth the meek are
inheriting the Earth but not in the way
that it's biblical in the way that we
we'd like to see it it's not the
underdog rising up
okay so my question is
do you think that men are weaker in 2022
100 yes in what way though I think
there's something still playing blessing
oh they're topic okay
from from what I think
I'm going to compare the men I see now
to what my dad was hmm now my dad took
it overboard he was he was over like
masculine over
a misogynist if that's the word
um
whereas now
I'll talk about the physical side but
this is not the important side I'm just
saying
like now I'm a dancer I've been a dancer
for a few years
now I see dancers
putting on uh like makeup and just none
of it nothing wrong with that absolutely
nothing wrong with that but it's it's a
feminine trait right so it it also comes
into like the personality side where
the men I see now are not as tough as
probably my dad was he was he was he was
proper like
I run the house I don't cook The Woman
Cooks
um this is my role this is the woman's
role whereas now it's all it's all very
mixed
um so I'm just curious why is that
misogynist
you said misogynistic what why is what
like your dad like why why do you use
that word uh because he was he was he
was um he never cooked a meal in his
house not when he was with my mom or
with my stepmom
he would say that certain things are for
her to do and not for him to do anything
that was to do with like the cars and
fixing or DIY he would do it
that's not massaging that sounds perfect
that's just wrong that sounds perfect
yeah like if I could if I just got a
Coke he's fixing everything yeah he
would do all the like the hard labor
stuff whereas she would talk about all
the um this is good for women and I
would think that is where exactly I
think men are not many more they don't
do they don't do that yeah I don't do
that anymore they'll look at me and tell
me what do you bring to the table ask
them can you fix anything like do you
know how to fix anything can you fix a
toilet can he fix a car can you change
your tire do you have to do that must
men do now to do that I I like this I
like those trains I like those traits
too I like speaking to part of it and I
feel like you can still be a feminist
and have no you can still be a famous
and have traditional roles yeah but the
problem is like you guys aren't young
virgins
so you that's like demanding traditional
outcomes when you're not traditional
women
like if you're a traditional woman you'd
be a young virgin
like I don't know virgin birth yeah yeah
like like okay so you're you're
describing things you're saying to the
men like you're not traditional men and
I I agree but we're not traditional
women we're not 22 you're 21 year old
virgins the value Purity in youth the
average age of first marriage in the UK
is 31. that that's not Pure or youthful
how many bodies you got by 31. oh okay
loads yeah
I don't think men are getting weaker I
just think that Society
wants them what Society wants us to
believe it
and because nowadays everything's too
instant like you were saying about oh
men fix the car men do this men do that
nowadays your car breaks down they make
a phone call gets fixed yeah I mean we
as women we can we can do that you know
there are some women like I can fix my
car because I can I can put a light bulb
up I can I can I've got a table from
like a certificate in car maintenance so
but I'm not doing it I do the pink jobs
and he does but you know what I say I I
still like obviously we are not going to
be virgins at this age of course not but
um I I do like the fact that my partner
when something breaks in the house I
love seeing him take take out his tools
and doing that yeah and then oh baby let
me make your sandwich while you do that
I like that I still like that obviously
it's not going to be I'm not I'm not the
30 year old virgin hell no but no and
and I I agree with you like I think it's
attractive but it's just like we're
asking for traditional outcomes but
we're not traditional women oh no not at
all we're not no also I wouldn't have to
point out like the fact that I think
Paul pointed out as well that you use
the word misogyny which is a negative
word and I think what you explained was
your dad just having roles in the house
and relationship and I think I think
that's a pertinent thing to notice that
that that misogyny is like a disdain for
women yeah don't forget there's one of
those um keywords the one there was new
words that they use I'm writing them
down I'll be writing them down in a
minute all this all these words will
keep on coming out and everybody's using
this massage
is it a cataract or whatever it is
I agree when you say the word misogynies
not it's not good but the reason why I
say it is because he went he went
overboard like one time we were in a
restaurant I went I went to Konami back
on holiday and he was like oh let's go
have a meal in a restaurant
and um and we were at the restaurant and
the way the way he was treating the way
it was like bring me this and why are
you not bringing me this and I was like
because he to to him he was he was the
alpha male wherever he was or wherever
he went and because he had businesses
and and good status or whatever he he
carried himself like that and
that's why I say he was so misogynistic
that I I don't agree with it
he might just think to himself do you
know what I'm paying for a service and I
want to service right exactly yeah but
he did it in the like the wrong way and
he wasn't I mean he could be he could be
rude yeah what is what is misogynistic
to you
okay my understanding is some uh
masculine in its overbearing masculine
no that that's what she actually thinks
though like I think people people modern
feminists that's what they actually
think they think misogyny is just being
a man it's masculinity that they think
that's the problem
um but it's at this damn woman so
misogyny is kind of like judging someone
purely based on their gender and kind of
an oppressive way I think like saying
things like you you can't it's the
hatred of women yeah but the action of
misogyny is is kind of like you can't
you can't have this job because your
woman you know XYZ that's how it you
know it shows itself it's not being rude
to a waiter or saying uh my wife she
cooks I pay for the bills that's not my
suggestions being you know a man who
believes in roles maybe overbearing at
times but do you know I was just
thinking heard that sounds like a older
version of Andrew Tate
[Music]
he didn't have a big mouth like Tate
does but he was he was very in his
actions very that's the woman's role and
this is the man's role and there ain't
no in between and that's fair enough you
have a right to Define roles in your
relationship is consensual right if if I
say you have to do this and I do this
yeah but you know something about even
though she looks in it as if it's
something negative it worked for
appearance
and it works for them I noticed they
like aspects of it so no one complains
that like you know my dad was paying too
much of the bills and taking care of too
much stuff and really kind of protect us
too much it's only like random small
things then it's like misogyny and you
know the the thing is though oh do they
get the more they realize you know what
I I want to be like my parents but they
didn't have it so bad because the older
you get you're going to realize that all
of these roles that they had it works it
works and everybody's going towards
traditional and they're looking at their
parents and thinking no they were too
traditional but when you think about it
look at the longevity of your parents
relationship compared to the longevity
of the relationships now where people
decide they want to mix modern with
traditional which don't work it never
works Auntie would you describe yourself
as a modern woman no would you how would
you describe yourself because you've
said you're not traditional so I would
say I'm a traditionalist okay what does
that mean
that means that I'm not a virgin okay
and I'm having loads of sex
and I still know my place but I would
say that if I was a virgin and I was at
the same person and I was married I'm
traditional I'm not I'm just an old bird
with Traditional Values how how do you
feel do you feel like over a certain age
modern women cannot have traditional
outcomes anymore it's a I had the same
conversation today with him indoors
and
he just he it was just like they get to
this age
after being so modern
and they hit like the 35s and they think
you know what it's not working for me I
want to be traditional but then
the men that are out there that are one
traditional they don't want them because
the women are coming with this modern
values
trying to be traditional and you know
what you've got it or you ain't and you
can't mix the two you cannot mix the two
and women are out there they're too busy
trying to be modern but traditional but
no they're not even trying to be like a
normal woman with Traditional Values
they want to be modern and traditional
and they're going to crash they're gonna
crash because the two can't work
together no matter what they say it
can't work I'm telling you it cannot
work you cannot be modern and
traditional at the same time modern is
all about look it up in the dictionary
modern is all about me me me me me
traditional is about us the village
raising everybody together so you can't
turn around and say oh I'm gonna be
modern it's all about me and I'm gonna
do traditional because it does not work
it's impossible you're fooling yourself
if you think you can be modern with
Traditional Values if I turned around
and I said oh I'm a traditionalist and
I'm gonna be modern I'm gonna go out I
want to get my nails done I'm going to
I'm gonna get my hair done I want to get
makeup on my definitely you're kidding
yourself look at her old woman do you
know what I mean oh my undressers lamb
they're not going to accept it from a
traditional old person like me trying to
be modern so why do they think it's
gonna work that way around it don't yeah
how how do you feel like we can return
do you do you think there is any
returning to traditionalism for modern
women like is there any way they can do
it no forget about model minimum I want
to start my grandchildren's age and the
children because there's no hope for
them the only thing I can do is all the
modern women you try and sort yourself
out for your children and raise the Next
Generation because these people now
they lost they lost they're fighting
against themselves they're fighting to
they're fighting to hold on to something
that is not good for them
that is proven that it's not good for
you so all this modern
Nest that they want it's not working
there's nothing wrong with being
traditional and the thing is it only
hits them when they get to a certain age
and they think you know [ __ ] I've got
this I want this I want this and where's
the man
do you think most men are traditional
yeah I think deep down they are deep
down in the backbones of the men they
are but is finding a woman that would
work with them and the men are too busy
trying to bend to This Modern Woman
rather than Dash them and leave them do
you think from all cultures or specific
all cultures all cultures before you can
say it's them you can say like it's the
the people in is spreading it's like the
plague it's like a modern plague or even
places where you think it's not going to
happen all of a sudden
they've got people on Instagram and they
live in a village where they live in a
village back wherever it is and you can
see them and then and they're doing the
dances and everybody wants to be no no
no no no it's leaking into society and
if we don't stop it now it's gonna
you're gonna end up with
it's gonna end up a mess really because
sooner or later they're gonna be no
children being born they're going to
cutting down they're gonna be no
children being born because the modern
women are going to be too old to breed
and then the old the the the people that
they want don't want them and Men quite
happily after certain age they're gonna
put you know what I've got to the age
where I don't want no crying kids in my
head I'd rather just chill have my own
place live off my own wealth and forget
about it so I think now we need to work
on the the children that are in school
now because what we're showing them now
is wrong and the thing is the modern
woman knows it's wrong and rather than
turn around like me I have messed up my
whole life I have messed up my whole
life I'm not gonna turn around and say
oh yes I've had a perfect relationship
oh yes I've had the perfect life but you
know what if I can avoid somebody else
going through the crap that I have I'm
gonna try my hardest but too many people
are out there and rather than say you
know what I've learned this I'm gonna
pass it down they're not passing it down
they're making it look as if it's all
right and I don't understand that
because if it's not working for you why
not pass it on to the next Generation so
they can see that it's not working but
you know what just to say quickly the
solution is not really going back to
traditionalism the solution is
instilling people with self-love so that
they can value themselves and find the
right people
modern women are obsessed with
themselves look at [ __ ] Instagram but
that's that they're up that's a
difference there's a difference there's
Obsession and there's like seriously
true
um installation of confidence and
self-love and what I mean by self-love
no no no what are you talking about I'll
tell you what I mean show me to tell you
what it means okay okay tell me what it
means okay no stress self-love means
that you are able to understand what
you're good at what you're bad at what
is ugly about you which means that when
you go for somebody you're not going to
let somebody make you feel less than and
you're not going to go for somebody that
is way more than you so you go stand in
your lane modern women loves themselves
so much that they think they deserve
this
stop stop modern women love themselves
so much that they think they deserve the
men that they sleep with even though
those men do not commit to them do you
think and then they come back back and
scream trauma do you think that the
women that are showing off on social
media doing a lot of these things I
think that self-love or is that actually
a lot of insecurity I think it's
narcissism I think most modern women are
very narcissistic they're usually
obsessed with themselves they think that
they're tense they think that they're
special when you're literally average
narcissism comes from insecurities no I
would disagree
no the narcissist is an extremely
insecure person who feels rejected I
think this is like I think this is
Modern Woman Babel where they try to
psychoanalyze everybody
stop stop stop they think that they
think that they're they psychoanalyze
everybody and they think that they're a
therapist and they think that they're a
psychologist and they can just
psychoanalyze narcissists literally
think they're better than everyone they
think they're perfect they can do no
wrong it's a front thank you
psychological condition
everybody reads Freud for narcissism it
is not insecure baby that person is very
knows who they are no they know do you
know they know do you know the
definition of
I think it's insecurity because that
would mean you're right I think it's
need to be right right now excuse me
okay a narcissist a person who has an
excessive interest or admiration of
themselves it is not insecure where does
this stem from okay
individual person I I went deep into
research about nothing because I was
okay okay but like this like right here
this this is a narcissistic trait like
this this interaction because you think
you know the definition better than the
actual definition you're like rewrite
writing words so you can be right well
no I'm not go search for it and go for
all the psychology journals you tell
them the The Narcissist it starts from
youth where actually they go quality
Journal so many I don't even know what
to tell which one when I was going
through it which one just Google it's
just Google
um just put like how narcissists just
like that just and go check and actually
narcissism actually stems from the fact
that the child either was ignored when
they were young and so they did
everything to come to come from
attention or it literally okay this is
this is from Mayo Clinic do we do we
agree Mayo Clinic yes or no how do we
feel about Mayo Clinic I don't think so
um
I'm a scientist I will take you with a
pinch of salt gold I can pick a
different one though there's no peer
review that was just the first one
symptoms have an exaggerated self
exaggerated sense of self-importance
have a sense of entitlement and require
constant excessive admiration oh
actually go through this I want you to
think of if these describe modern women
like as I as I go through these
expect to be recognized as Superior even
without achievements that warrant it
exaggerate achievements and talents be
preoccupied with fantasies about success
power Brilliance beauty or the Perfect
Mate
believe that they are superior and can
only associate with equally special
people monopolize conversations and
belittle or look down on people they
perceive as inferior expect special
special favors and unquestioning
compliance with their expectations take
advantage of others to get what they
want have an inability or unwillingness
to recognize the needs and feelings of
others be envious of others and believe
others Envy them behave in an arrogant
or haughty manner coming from a
conceited boastful and pretentious
insists on having the best of everything
for instance the best car office Etc did
that describe modern women that sounded
like um like like she said that sounded
like somebody really insecure
exactly exactly
a little bit but no a little bit but no
all I wanted to say is
yeah
also also um causes environment genetics
neurobiology
um environment mismatches and
parent-child relationships either with
an excessive adoration or excessive
criticism that is poorly attuned to the
child experience genetics inherited
characteristics neurobiology the
connection between the brain and
behavior and thinking risk factors
narcissistic personality affects more
males than females doubt it no no no no
I was about to say that I'm so sorry
about you all I wanted to say is that it
sounds like the modern woman but it
sounds like the mother woman who's
trying to catch up with the man oh
that's what it sounds to me do you
understand because that's meant for you
man that run companies whatever have
they lift the finger male privilege why
privilege you understand like you think
men that run companies don't have to
lift a fingers no no I'm just crazy well
well well I don't they may not work as
hard as well I said
no we have now have to look at the
companies okay I'm talking the same the
man of say 50 60 years ago the Modern
Woman of today is trying to catch up
with that man 50 60 years ago yeah the
one that was very pumped and stuff like
full of himself like the characteristics
you read what I see is not current men
because also what's funny is that we
started this conversation say what's
wrong with the man and then we now look
at the woman and what's faulty with her
and that's what's funny here that's what
I'm trying to say so it's like the woman
is faulty but who's the woman trying to
emulate she's trying to catch up with
the man so really the women just need to
know their place now they're women
they're not men and they can't catch up
with men and then he said as they said
hold their own lane and be women and
allow the men to be men yeah but when we
say be in their Lane people should not
get offended by your lane does not mean
in the kitchen you understand your lane
doesn't mean in the house in your lane
could be like okay if you know that
engineering is not for a female field
leave it for the man go find your field
that is the lane that's like find what
you prosper in yeah no no but what I'm
saying stay in your lane she's saying
like understand understand your position
don't overplay your position and that is
valid for everybody in life not just
male or female I guess I think I think
when a unique time period of time where
I think because of you know everyone
being able to work I think we really
need to like readdress how we relate to
each other as men and women so I
wouldn't I wouldn't as much say like you
know people should stay in their roles
and Etc but I really think there needs
to be like a really conscious effort to
kind of re-rebalance that that
relationship because it's not the 1960s
anymore so the rebalance means still
restructuring those roles so yeah know
your position
the only difference is is that years ago
everybody was happy as they are no now
listen listen you born years ago I was
no I don't know right we cannot finish
yeah but I don't bother you wouldn't be
here okay
years ago
one wage
would have kept the whole house that's
what people prefer to realize one wage
would have kept a whole house so the men
went out and worked and the women stayed
home done their side hustles and the
women ran the house
then all of a sudden they wanted bigger
houses they wanted bigger so then it
took two people to go and work the
difference is that two people can work
and still have those same roles and when
people
think about men having their roles and
women have their roles I worked
my other half worked
I would say like we have pink jobs and
blue jobs but he cooks better than me if
he comes home first he's gonna cook it
doesn't diminish his role as a man thank
you and it's all about cooperation and
that's the only difference between then
and now is that one wage could have kept
a whole household now the way things are
changing the way things are moving you
need two wages but because now you need
two wages it doesn't mean that you're
equal
somebody still has to lead but the women
are thinking oh I earn my own money now
and he earns his own money so all these
rules are outdated no
I don't think they're outdated I just
think that you still need to work
together and you can still have those
roles there's people out there that have
got married that have still got
Traditional Values they're bringing in
two wages and they make it work because
they each know their roles and because
they are traditional like from the start
not like oh I'm going to be a modern
woman then all of a sudden I'm going to
forget that I'm not a virgin and get
married and I'm traditional I'm talking
about the ones that are traditional from
the start like get married and work it
out and I know I know a few young people
like that like your age and a bit older
that are married with Children and they
both work but they still have
traditional roles they still have
traditional roles
can I say what if some women are waiting
to find the man with traditional roles
are they traditional women
you have to adapt to society
traditional women are suffering bad I've
been seeing a lot of videos of virgins
coming out and I say we also need to be
recognized
are we talking about it's like sexually
like I'm very yeah
women like my view is that if you're not
a virgin like you're a virgin you get
married that's the way it was back then
that is traditional you can be a
traditionalist if you're not a virgin
you are not traditional in my view you
are a traditional list can I say
something that's kind of strange that I
actually noticed because I've been
watching a lot of like time periods of
movies
the Purity that we talk about in virgins
the tradition that come from like
centuries realistically there's like a
pervy old man that were kind of like
trying to bite children from like other
families I'm not gonna lie my
grandmother my granddad
that's rubbish my grandmother my
granddad they got married and my grand
my my grandmother died at 100 years old
my granddad weren't pervy and they were
both virgins I'm not talking about your
granddaughter I'm trying to say that you
can't say a whole generation that
because it was traditional then that was
old men and pervy that they were perving
on young people well okay I I was put in
another way don't generalize don't
generalize I'll just put into another
way I'm not you're picking like a nice
you know a nice example that is
beautiful well stop thinking the bad
ones
I'm giving it up that's great that's
fantastic another example like child
marriage it happens all over the world
it's just because and these are the more
traditional places in the world in the
Western World marriages in the western
I'm just explaining I'm just explaining
yeah that the more traditional places in
the world this happens so if we in the
Western World we're trying to go back
into motivational where does it happen
Africa age
we don't know about child marriage no my
life you can't take extreme examples no
no no no no no because even Nigeria even
Africa is westernized I see people that
in Africa that speak speak like Nathan
and they've never been to America you
understand yeah so you can't say in
Africa okay you can't take extreme
examples to explain what you're trying
to say child marriage
no no I'm saying that they speak like
Americans
no no no no no no I'm saying that
there's people in that speak like
they're American and they've never been
anywhere she's saying Africa Africa is
not what though
I'm African too I'm angolan I know what
I'm talking about what I'm mentioning is
I mentioned Africa mentioned Asia I
mentioned certain parts in the world are
more tradition
I'm talking about what I know
you're even like literally it's one of
the most this is quite normal I don't
know how people don't understand this
like how underage girls yeah that
shouldn't even be having sex with grown
men they're doing it because their
families are arranging this with it with
other families because of financial
gaining whatever and this has been the
tradition from back in the day kings and
queens days and that's what the idea of
Purity being what is favorite that's
where it comes from realistically if we
really stop to think about it and some
of the most traditional like the ones
that have not been tainted by Western by
Western
um by Western ideals the majority of
marriages in Angola are not child
marriage oh by the way don't listen to
the stats this is a communist country
that actually said that wow
you don't come out
actually come and do that because it's
not fair like don't like it
it doesn't happen in Angola it like
child marriage does happen okay it does
happen it's something that is it's a
problem even even genital
um yes and yeah mutilation those are
things but now you see we're in a
society where we recognize this as it is
not meant to be like this right so this
is why these issues are addressed but
what we're talking about is about modern
uh modern even in Nigeria there's no
more even I'm Igbo do you know how to
say I'm a traditional traditional that
tradition is still not there not it's
traditional list like you said but it's
not as traditional what's the difference
between culture
the legal age for marriage for both men
and women in Angola is 18 years old you
are right it's more prevalent it's more
it's more prevalent than it is here but
you you you speak as if it's
it's a oppressing like right why are you
speaking on something you don't know
I'll tell I'll tell you because I do
know one and then I'll tell you I'll use
another example I'm just all I'm trying
to do is exposure
I don't know because it's interesting
because what I like to do yeah is I like
people to explore their different ideas
for example you're telling go back to
the most traditional thing at EG Boko
Haram yeah this is just an example it's
extreme but just to explain what
traditionalism no but wait Boko Haram
what they stand for is basically against
Western culture because Western culture
in their eyes tainted the tradition what
is meant to be there what should be
there what do they do they take girls
and they marry them all over the world
or um all over all over like the place
they kidnapped them in fact and they're
my children and all I'm saying is that
actually the traditional idea the
traditional view of Purity is not
stemming from a woman why does a woman
have to be visual why does she have sex
is that traditional okay depending on
the culture no because no no no no no
because that is not traditional
throughout the whole West the world that
what you're talking about is tradition
that we is for that culture the Western
we call it the nice and that's why
that's culture for that culture is not
all over the Western World and things
are changing so that is it every
location if you look at how many child
marriages happen over the whole Western
World and look at the percentages it's
gonna be minute so you can't stand here
and make it like it's a majority because
it's not so traditional traditional
doesn't mean child marriages by pervial
men is what you're saying that's not
what I'm saying that is what you said
what I'm saying is for you to understand
I'm using you I don't want to understand
nothing you're saying I don't want to
understand you said that tradition means
that pervy old men are gonna go and
sleep with on the age do you know
the way YouTube example and then put it
into the context that's why I said that
you can't use that example to explain
what we're talking about and the one
thing you're taking I'm just the
question
the one thing the one thing you're
taking out of context from a historical
perspective is people did not live as
long it was not because the men were
pervs it was because people had to get
started a lot quicker in order to
reproduce it was a reproductive strategy
the reason that men like pure women is
because they had to ensure paternity if
you were sleeping around screwing the
whole town they didn't know if that kid
was theirs it's not it's not that
they're pervy that makes sense okay it
was what is the difference between a 17
and an 18 year old okay then I'll ask
another question can I ask you a
question then yeah another example cool
if that is the case if that is the case
then again I'll just say kings and
queens all these times they married
young girls and they were not the same
age yeah young virginal women are have
yes okay
no but life is expectancy back then was
even 35 I asked the Eastern Romans it
wasn't even 35. and the girls married
younger yeah people got married younger
because they did not live as long yeah
okay that was normal back then right
that was normal back then and while I'm
trying to explain this idea this idea of
Purity and youth is coming from an
outdated context I think that's a cope
because you don't have it anymore
women that sleep around that are not
virgins they will say that when again
they have lots of sex that will turn
around because they want to find men
they need a man that's what they're
going to turn around and say Purity
don't matter because it can't matter
where you've lost it because that's one
thing you can't get back that you're
giving away your virginity so that's why
you have to say that you have to say it
don't matter so that you can get a man
you know you can get operations now
was like I really don't I really don't
buy this idea I think this is like one
of these weird things that where like
traditionalists pretend that like the
past was some great place and everyone
was super happy all the time everyone
made these decisions monogamy was the
perfect for everyone everyone was really
happy in their marriage and I think it's
a bit more nuanced than that I've seen a
lot of examples
um enough for me to question that
narrative that like maybe maybe the
first or second guy you got with the
married wasn't the best fit maybe you
know do you know something right in the
back in those days you made your bed you
lie in it yeah yeah you made your
bedroom line it and once you line it you
make it work it wasn't about happiness
it was about you the difference as we do
we took away consequences now
so now now women have no consequence for
any decision they pick I'm sure I'm sure
women Back Then There Were ones that
wanted to leave and probably could if
there wasn't a consequence you know
something about years ago if I had sex
and I got pregnant I'm stuck
think about it and if that was a if that
was a consequence now
and women knew that every time they sit
with a man they can get pregnant do you
think they'd be missing about and
sleeping around so much so you can't say
that you know things have changed now
that that was back in the day that they
won't happen because
they made it work and the thing is that
everybody all the modern people now they
think that I'm gonna get with a man and
it's going to be more Rosy you know what
I mean 32 years is bloody hard work I've
been through some [ __ ] and it's hard but
you make it work if that was the case
it's too easy to turn around and say you
know what it don't work for me I'm Gonna
Leave You never had that back in the day
because if you turned around and you had
sex with a man and you got pregnant and
you didn't make it work you were a
failure
but surely there are cases so so I get
that in the past relationships had you
know they had to just deal with it and I
had to be pragmatic and and stoic and
that has its benefits right but surely
that's not what fits for every situation
surely there are situations where women
having the freedom to choose another
path albeit you know maybe a path that
in the in the end would lead her to be a
single cat lady surely there's
situations where you could say all right
you know that wasn't a good marriage and
maybe this is not one of them this is
where societies let women down I'm the
last of them when I had my son and I was
a single parent it wasn't like now I
shame on the family so it wasn't a
matter of fact of saying oh I'm gonna go
out there and I'm gonna have a child and
then it don't work for me it's not a fit
because if you didn't if you went out
there years ago and you had a child it
didn't fit you know what you didn't fit
in society you did not fit everybody's
talking about the modern women
everybody's talking about after women's
you know what they're not talking about
spinsters
and you know what that's what you don't
know what a spinster is someone who
pretends to be no Google it so that I
don't get it wrong
and that is what no no no that is what
the modern women nowadays are gonna end
up to be a good old-fashioned it's an
old-fashioned word believe you me a
spinster and years ago you did not want
to be a spinster just as nowadays you
shouldn't want to be a leftover woman
what's a spinster Pearl um an unmarried
woman typically an older woman beyond
the usual age for marriage oh what is
what age okay what age was considered a
Spencer spinster the word spinster was
used to refer to a single woman between
the ages of 23 to 26. while thornback is
reserved for those 26 and above nowadays
people are getting insulted with the
word leftover years ago you get insulted
in full shame if you were called a
spinster that's the only difference
exactly it's the same thing but for me
now I didn't know nothing about this
modern woman I knew that to be a
Catwoman or a dog lady you are a
spinster okay I I I I do get where
you're coming from I would say I differ
in the fact that I I think we let women
down in society down by promoting the
wrong we we don't promote like the right
values now I think we encourage women to
be masculine and we tell men to be weak
and need to be emotional and everyone
should have their space in the victory
you know something I don't know I think
that's what I think that well not us but
yeah the big people at the top who want
us to grab the message thank you I think
I think that's that's the real issue in
it because if you were promoting the
virtues of being a woman of being
agreeable being Pleasant or being
someone who can coexist who adds value
and Synergy to a man if you're promoting
resilience in men and saying listen life
happens you've got to be stronger hit
the gym work on yourself be someone
strong a strong man will naturally
settle down in it because we don't have
time to mess around with all four but
you know something back in the day the
men were hot sexy and muscular and they
never had no gym and the women never had
no flabby arms you know why because they
never had no gym they didn't have no
microwave they didn't have the washing
machine they didn't have no rice cooker
they did they had to go and wash my hand
and you see with the nowadays I've seen
people like doing um I can't if I get
everyone like Gary and fruitful they're
doing it in a blender in the microwave
two years ago you had to get it there
and that's why you got rid of all of
this you know what I mean you got rid of
all of that so you didn't have to go to
no gym yeah you didn't have to go and
the men didn't have to go to no gym the
men were naturally toned and good
because they have to work with their
hands and modernization has caused
people to be lazy yeah my point is that
it's it's not giving women more freedom
I think that that's I don't think that's
why we've gone wrong I think we've given
them more freedom and then promoted the
wrong paths so it's like nah I feel like
we should get rid of freedom for women
and I feel like I feel like I feel like
let's remove options there's too many
options these days as well everyone
thinks that everyone is replaceable like
before you said every you make your bed
you lie in there yeah that's your thing
you take it you pick till you choose it
you take it go but that's values
okay what would happen if divorce was
illegal divorce is my legal it's having
a 50 percent
what would happen if divorce was illegal
you make better choices what would
happen if you were legally married to
anyone you had a child with oh wait say
that again what happened married to
anyone you had a child
and divorce was illegal
yeah you would you would make better
choices I really believe in the mange
marriages you do I believe in the
old-fashioned marriages where the
cultures I don't care what culture it is
where you get the the mummies and the
daddies and the aunties and they come
together and and a lot of people I've
got a lot of engine I couldn't in my
children
some of them have love marriages some of
them have the range marriages and a lot
of people think the main marriage is
like
that's the man that's you you're gonna
go together but there's a lot of work
that goes into it and I've seen it in
Africa and I've seen it in my African
friends as well where they all get
together and they decide you know what
if this is the man you like let's check
out his family let's check out his
background let's come together and talk
and the weird thing is I was in Barbados
and my nephew
was having a baby with a girl
and my sister my late sister was oh I'm
going to meet the family I'm like what
do you mean oh well he's having a baby
we need to go and meet the family my
first view was saying in a minute they
never called you when they were having
sex how come now they're pregnant you're
gonna go meet the family but apparently
it was their thing that you got my
daughter pregnant oh my daughter allows
you to get her pregnant and all the
family they come together and they sit
down and they discuss what's going to
happen and I'm talking not like 50 years
ago I'm talking this has happened like
five ten years ago and it still goes on
in certain societies where you get
pregnant or you get together we're gonna
get together and talk and I think there
needs to be a village it can be done
that Village that that Village needs to
be there that Village and that's what's
missing because everybody's doing their
own thing and saying that this is right
and that is not wrong but if they have
their own village together to get
together and help them make decisions
because I even know like um I had
African people and when they were having
a problem in their relationships before
all this social media I'm like where you
go oh I'm going to see my uncle I have
to speak to them
I have to go I don't know what do you
mean or if the girl gets pregnant where
are you going I'm going my mother is
coming I'm I'm having a baby I'm like
what do you mean nope it's tradition you
go and you take either the mother come
off it was weird but it works out and I
understand it now I had African friends
and when they have a baby
my friend law moves in yeah for three
months at least you see what I mean and
and that was fantastic because she was
show her how to cope how to cook you can
do all of this and all of that while
she's having the children
the mother-in-law and she helps and
teaches her while she's having a baby
and nowadays it's like I'm gonna have a
baby and I'm gonna have this we're your
parents where is that and I'm not
talking about years ago because I saw
this happening like 20 years ago yeah
and it works ultimately to me it works
especially with the African societies
but now you get these new modern African
people and they don't want to go to
their Elders it'd be great if you've got
a problem rather than go on social media
and talk about it go to your elders that
is what is that is what is good about
some of the tradition is that they're
there for your backup and I'm so used to
like my African friends going and
talking to their Elders or I used to
find it really weird like you and your
husband having problems and you're
having this meeting you go in the house
it's like the whole room is full of all
these old people and you're sitting down
there discussing your problems and it
works because the ultimate Foundation of
society's family and family name family
structures are lacking these days
unfortunately because me as well till
today there's a problem my dad would be
like I'm calling yeah like and I'm like
oh God but because Society has now made
us very self-absorbed my feelings my
feelings my feelings we don't want other
people to in you know intrude and the
thing is because you know that all your
whole family is getting involved don't
that change your behavior absolutely
shame thank you so there's certain
things that you won't do or there's
certain things you won't let them know
about you can't you can't bring like the
the come up like rapper back to your dad
and say oh no no my only straight up if
you're coming into my house anybody who
meets my dad be ready to marry me no
that's that's what I'm saying like
because girls will go for like the bad
guys
I'm saying like that wouldn't that
wouldn't happen you know so I just use
Like Rappers yeah yeah but for me some
some of them are good and juicy sorry
years ago when you took your let's say
like if you went and you said oh this is
my partner um
what are your intentions towards my
daughter yes can I see your bank account
what is your job what are you and all of
that yeah and I remember going to like
weddings where I always thought it was
Indian people that had Diaries and I
remember having African friendly had all
this suitcase for the new clothes and
presents hair and jewelry there and I'm
like what are you doing I have to show
the family that I can support her yes
and it's like a whole ceremony of like
showing them what you can give showing
the family and that's what I mean
nowadays it's too easy for people to go
and get married they have to show the
family that they can look after that the
problem is the women nowadays aren't
worth it like why would I do all that
when she's out here in the street
why would I do that for a 31 year old
wife because I I've experienced this
recently and you know obviously I don't
have these traditional views right so
you know some of these guys are out here
counting body counts for me it's more
like in the way they act like I I I
messed around with like an older woman
like a few months ago 42 only ever been
with one guy you know like I'm I can
just when I'm around her it's just like
she's from a different age there was no
no she's you know she's gorgeous so I'm
not running but she's from a different
age like just the way she behaves The
Way She carries herself the way she
talks very soft very pleasant not too
opinionated it's just like it's just
like that she's like a real woman that's
what I realized that being with her I
was like yo there's no one in my
generation that can like being around
someone like that was like you know what
I'm a bachelor I'm probably gonna be a
bachelor for the next five six seconds
but hanging out with her I was like yo I
actually get why people like get married
why was she on her own why is she 42 in
single fussy it's not your business I'm
not gonna I'm not gonna be saying that
okay I always say that's their story
like there's modern modern you know
problems have modern solutions but
there's a lot of stuff going on here in
London but still I'm not gonna lie um
do you want children uh ideally yeah oh
what shame what's stopping you are you
saying ideally
that's a bunch of things but meeting the
right person the reason I was asking
because that woman sound like she's
captured a bit of him but she's old you
know what I mean it's like actually no
children no one can capture maybe but I
think I think I was close I always
thought like if you were like 25 20
years younger that's why I asked about
yours
because you sounded like if she could
breathe and be healthy or whatever I'm
not I'm not missing out yeah I was just
like yeah yeah if you were like 20 years
younger yeah
I'll be getting some Factory job I'll be
like
did you have something you wanted to add
I forgot okay now you say you're not
gonna lie oh yeah yeah I ain't going
like um don't lie I'm scared to get
married why because um The Generation
Now compared to back in the days I'm
talking before we were born it was
different like back in the days when
when they meet each other they get
married and they just stay together you
know what I'm saying about a generation
now it's like it's bad it's toxic what I
mean by that is that everybody's just
breeding each other everybody's having
babies with you and then they never
without that same person do you get what
I'm trying to say and it's scary man
I've seen it so many times with a lot of
people and it affects me the reason why
I say it affects me because it's not
free on the child and excuse me imagine
that you want to get married now that's
what I'm saying I've always said like
like say full song for me I have a son
I tried so hard obviously to make the
relation work
yeah I'm not saying I'm perfect you know
what I'm saying but I was never
acquitted I see as like if you've made
her family just put like you gotta stick
together for life you know I mean but
our generation I think I blame the
social media I feel like it's that it's
a distraction this is my honest opinion
technology yeah but it's a technology so
that's why I'm scared to get me I'm
scared if I get married after three
years hold on wait a minute oh she's
gonna wanna take my money or she want to
take my house can I ask you a question
when was the last time you had sex
are you asking me yeah he's Jamaican
Nancy maybe like that I've got Jamaica
about fruit two days three days ago oh
are you serious about that person
no no because the reason I'm asking that
because the way he's describing I'm
tired of people saying oh this is what I
want and his things have changed and
they're contributing to all we have to
be that what we want we have to be
accountability you can't turn around and
say this is what I want but what are you
doing to make that happen to make that
happen because the change don't come
from out there the change comes from you
within and if you want to see a change
then it's down to each individual to
start making the change you can't turn
around and say this is what I want I
don't want to be paddling in a muddy
pool when you're helping make the pool
muddy
because at the end of the day what have
you got to choose from
that you've really crept in
that's why I say self-love I hear that
answer but then but you get to ever have
don't agree with the same thing even
though even though you two love that
person it's just you know what you need
to be you know you need to be you need
to be more fussy more selective and
treasure your dick self-love I'm not
gonna lie I'm about myself
as far as I'm concerned if you want
somebody good don't be dipping your dick
in somebody bad auntie I hear what
you're saying but for us men yeah and
I'm talking for us it's hard
enough you know what safe sex jerk off
then you're not messing with nobody's
mind you're not messing with nobody's
body there's no chance that any
contraception is gonna fail and that you
can preserve yourself
you need to be more fussy that's the
right idea but I think I think from a
man to man right I think you focus that
energy imagine you're saving that energy
for like the one in it kill it so but
masturbation porn I think is not the way
because
leads to leads to um oh man you're
leaving me hanging I was giving you spot
right now come on I used to other things
and then at least lack of discipline but
I would say Focus that imagine you're
saving that energy for the one in it and
it makes you all the more intense
because when you meet that one you pull
out all the steps
I'm just going to give you little
devil's advocate here okay I don't think
your generation really understands this
okay for for men like women like guys
that sleep around and and treat like
women modern women don't like men that
treat them like queens and the problem
is like if if guys
aren't sleeping around they start to
like think too highly of each girl and
treat them too well and modern women
don't like that it's not like in your
generation where like a girl's courted
and like they respect it and they're
excited like you can just Court the nice
girl and she she wants you like for them
it's like basically if they give a girl
everything She Wants then she doesn't
like them and girls don't like guys that
don't sleep around like they only want
guys that sleep around
if that's the case
and you've really got a child
don't have number one get old woman I
hate our energy but then you get there's
some woman out there just just no I said
get an older woman an old mature woman
like the woman that he said that he
found one that's feminine she can't
breathe you've already got a son you
don't want no more children concentrate
on your one child have a happy
relationship with woman that can't
breathe
problems
[Laughter]
so my my what I think is it's modern
times cool for modern solutions in it
like that that free market of people
sleeping around with each other I think
that's always existed I think it's
always going to exist
um I think the fact that women value men
who are more experienced I think is a
sign of that just the selection in this
daily game has gotten a lot tougher I
think that back in the day guys guys
would get with women just because
they're in the right place and we're
born in the same Village she could be a
Victoria Secret model you could look
like you know Shrek and it's just like
well we were the same age I had a good
job it worked our parents liked each
other now you really have to work you
really have to be the guy in it and so I
I would I would definitely kind of
that's what I want to add that like it's
not all bad in it it was just another
stat to kind of give you some
perspective women modern women find 80
percent of men as unattractive and so on
dating apps which people will argue that
maybe people on dating apps aren't
looking for something serious but that's
the number one way people meet women
only swipe right five percent of the
time up to 20 on the high end in certain
studies so women are all sleeping with
the same guys so for guys that are in
that percentage it's like they just have
an abundance of girls throwing
themselves at them and then the women
will come back later and say men are
trashed up but that's who who we need to
have a speed dating thing me and you
will yeah I have we need to set up a
speed dating or even a quoting thing
when we show them how to do it properly
and give them questions to ask you know
speed dating but we provide the
questions
we're helping me open wife school right
yes things turn modern women into wives
you need to try we need to do it what we
need to do we don't want to be saved no
they do I think some do you know what
right I want one more thing but I think
they do they want to have their fun and
you know but stop it Alex don't say that
like oh
what you're saying is right I'm not
saying that is wrong but why does it
always boil down to women
okay no don't say no because you see
what Nathan said I like you Nathan by
the way I appreciate girl but what made
me feel like you're not scared you're
more like scared to be stuck in one
because there's so many options out
there because you keep dipping your
cookie into the jars different jars of
different sauces so but here's here's
the reason so I think sorry the reason
why you don't want to come in I feel
like the way you explain to me to one
jar is because you're like oh because
you saw the other jar you saw the other
day you're like it might taste you said
too many options that's what you said
earlier
let me explain it to you so women leave
women divorce men 70 to 80 percent of
the time I I would argue in
relationships it's probably similar men
aren't leaving women are so to a guy's
point of view he's going to commit to
this girl and what does he get he
doesn't get Purity anymore you know
these These Hoes you know he doesn't he
doesn't get youth anymore so he doesn't
get either of those things a lot of
times she already has a kid so so he's
not fulfilling his mating strategy on
top of that even if he does find a good
woman that maybe has the qualities he's
looking for she was going to want him to
marry her right and what does he get out
of that oh she can leave and take half
and take my kids and she's paid to take
my kids away from me she she gets more
money if she takes my children and so
from the men's point of view they're
just kind of like effort because like
women aren't wives nowadays
and what do they get out of it men are
logical they're logical people and so
they're thinking does the benefit
outweigh the cost and like I just think
as women we have to look at ourselves
and say the benefits we bring nowadays
don't outweigh the cost for most men
you know for the for the sake of
argument and finally it's about my turn
to you know help the boys out I'll tell
you something boys do you know the best
way for you to deal with a modern woman
be stush
stush means be a bit more stuck up about
yourself because actually girls don't
like rejection and when we reject one
she wants you more because it's a
challenge at that moment you've got the
power if you want her you want to
maneuver and check while she's on and
you want to get her in your in your
books but okay
listen to this listen to this from the
men's point of view so I have to play a
bunch of games with these women in order
to get to them to to commit to me why do
it at all
because because why is it worth it yeah
it's like what what is the benefit to
the men like what genuinely who who in
here has a cookbook maybe maybe you need
a cookbook what I do
are you ask me no my point is none of us
in here are can be considered
traditional women and back then an
average guy could get a traditional
woman and now what does he get he gets a
boss [ __ ] a boss babe a girl that's
been ran through he gets an ex-ho he
gets a born-again virgin like this is as
as women this is what what do we get we
still get protection and provisioning
are you sure and I mean
I mean okay okay but here's here's the
thing the average salary could cover an
apartment
and but the thing is like women we want
this lifestyle that's not even realistic
nowadays like we want men that make more
than we do and we want them to pay all
of the bills but it's like we work we
all have our nails done we have
um we get our hair dyed we have makeup
we have all of this stuff that costs
money because we want this lifestyle and
I've had girls come on my show and I say
would you would you date an average guy
for a companionship but you would have
to go down in lifestyle and they say no
we're addicted to Lifestyle
I would add from a male perspective what
what I find and I think that this is why
most guys don't bother and this is you
know why I I you know for me it's the
biggest kind of consumer of my energy
when it comes to dating in this whole
game is that everyone every all modern
women want my time and attention to them
when I go to a club there's 10 hot girls
who think I'm gonna get their number
talk to them for three months take them
out until they eventually decide to you
know we can do this or that or whatever
and it's it's just non-stop and they all
they all think they all think I have all
the time in the world and that they're
also special and interesting and that
they all deserve the red carpet
treatment and these women do nothing for
me they do absolutely nothing they come
barely hold a conversation they can't
start a conversation they've got no Day
ideas they don't even know how to be
feminine from they're saying that they
think wearing a tight skirt is feminine
you can stand around and guys would just
throw themselves at you which is which
is kind of like that's that's why which
is what they do and that's why I said
when is the last time a girl planned a
day for you oh my God like like plans
like a planned a whole day got you a
really a thoughtful gift that had
nothing to do with her nothing she
wanted I'm glad you asked that question
I don't remember the last time they
didn't do it but they talk about
equality a lot you guys but you're
generalizing a lot like even even if it
was just making fact that maybe liked
you or got feelings or whatever did any
of them like try to compete for you hell
no yeah
because it's an ego thing because girls
won't put aside their ego
Queens they're all boss [ __ ] no she's
got a point for once I'll agree with her
she does have a point girls do you know
what stop being so annoying if you have
if you want to see the guy ask him can I
see you if you want to go on a date with
him and you invite him make sure that
you did the invitation be polite have
manners and you're the one that is the
host there for you to patent the thing
stop always waiting for the guy to make
the first move I get the Impressions
you can't turn around and say that the
men want feminine women so how can a
woman go up to a man and say I'm gonna
take you out well also
I think that you're an amazing guy you
are sick I'm gonna shoot my shoes
so so devil's advocate here I I'm not I
wouldn't probably approach it like that
but like back in the day didn't women
drop the handkerchief
right right women drop the handkerchief
but that's what that you see the thing
is right is that years ago you dropped a
handkerchief and the man showed you was
interested you didn't drop your knickers
and that's the difference drop in a
handkerchief is totally different from
dropping your knickers
so you used to walk along in the old
days they used to drop a hat you know
you walk along and you drop a hanky just
to see whether or not the man was
interested
but now the women are dropping their
knickers to see whether the man's
interest no I don't think that's an
issue they're not dropping their
knickers because most like a third of
men as virgins but they're dropping
their knickers more than me drop hankies
no my my my only point was that like
when is the last time as like as a woman
like you've really showed effort to show
a man that you appreciate him and you're
interested I know you do YouTube I'm
saying like
um go ahead go ahead sorry
um I was gonna say so you know you guys
are speaking about this
what do you think of someone who's been
in a relationship in a long relationship
like I'll give you an example
um I've been with my partner for like a
year and a half now and the other day I
said Tim we like to do date nights we
like to keep it spicy and we have a
child right it's not his child but he he
takes on the role brilliantly love that
yeah and I said to him
um Monday night you're booked date night
meet me at this hotel I've booked the
hotel I've filled it with balloons
petals everything
um and and I did that for him so what
what do you think of that like I'm
treating him no but on the flip side you
fight sometimes so but you know
something right that would work for you
uh-huh and if it works for you that's
great I appreciate that but that
wouldn't work for me so something
totally different like for you booking a
hotel and that I don't like hotels I'm
fussy about my food I hate flowers okay
so just call you the date night but then
you you pick whatever you want there's
nothing wrong in that yeah but the thing
is is that sometimes don't even tell him
surprise surprise him yeah yeah surprise
him he doesn't need to be told no he
wasn't told he was just told he was
given an address but also he's given an
address and be there
nothing can I just say something
interesting that I've observed um
because I've given this example a lot
and whenever like women say the thing
that they did for their boyfriend or
their husband or whatever it was it's
always something that like women would
enjoy yeah yeah I don't I don't know him
maybe this was like you know I'm sure he
appreciated either way but it's just
interesting like I think a lot of times
we look through our point of view and
not there but you know what you just
reminded me of something it's Pearl is
so right when she said that because
remember I said that that wouldn't work
for me but
what actually worked for me was
Christmas
and I said you know what because we
don't live together because I'm my mom's
caregiver so it's impossible because of
the way I am because my mom's got
Dimensions she's really Sublime so I
look after my mum so hence the two
separate houses but I said you're going
to spend Christmas
and I've planned it so that I hate
movies and he's a nerd he loves movies
The Only We Love alcohol
and we love good food
and it was Christmas my birthday is this
after Christmas and he had such a
relaxing time
I forgot my birthday
and I only remembered my birthday my
birthday was in December
and we only we didn't have Christmas
dinner
we realized that I think the new year
was that what happened to Christmas
dinner when I said it was still in the
fridge you know because we ate and we
snack and to him he loved that yeah but
for me to go and do something that I
mean I was sat down there when I'm
watching the movie marathon I hate
movies but that is something that he
enjoys because the thing is that in
relationships I always say that we
always think about what we want but we
never think about what we can give can I
can I say one thing I feel like I'm in
this is my opinion I feel like there's
one part of it where all you women are
forgetting right
um when men are
going out of the way to give you stuff
or do some surprise for y'all
the one for y'all keep forgetting
there's one important thing that we want
our back too but we don't like to say I
mean y'all always say the word fangs or
you won't give us a team but we like
back you know what I'm saying like it's
always us men going our way to do stuff
for the women to get you know I mean but
we don't we don't get it back you don't
give it to receive that's right I'm just
saying like like we love it like you see
how we do some surprise things or we
take you out we like it back and that's
why I said I think the point they're
trying to make um and I I agree with you
I don't think you should give so you
should can receive but I think a lot of
men just feel like women put in no
effort nowadays yes
100 I think what it means is that the
men put in too much effort now probably
because you know what right all the
things that he's saying everybody to say
to my man oh yeah I want you to book a
hotel I guess we're gonna go you're
gonna explain it on your own because
that is not that's too much
do you know what I mean I'm happy with
him if I come to his house and there is
curry goat and rice and salad
yeah I'm in heaven that's that's it for
me I was gonna say yummy that's it for
me the society the the societal
narrative in there that men are
constantly told that we're dispensable
and that our time and energy doesn't
mean anything so when I coach when I
coach guys right because I do date
coaching on the side now it's the first
step is always to help them to
understand that like you have value bro
like like guys just have this idea that
like oh it's pick up Artistry so I'm
going to read this book and learn these
patterns and do this and then when she
does this I'm going to do this and I'm
thinking Bro you've forgot one thing
self-respect you haven't even judged
this person like these some of these
guys who are new to The Dating Game
often go into clubs and they give their
time and attention to People based on
looks and I'm standing there thinking I
can tell this one's got a boyfriend this
one's just for attention this one's
emotionally available actually likes the
other guy at the back of the room but
it's talking to you because you got game
but she's gonna waste your time later
modern guys have been so brainwashed and
told to be emotional and feminine and
like your time doesn't mean anything you
should be you should be lucky to have
any woman around you that they waste
their time and energy do you know the
one thing that my black guys do the one
thing that I find that modern guys do
which
no what modern guys don't do which my
man does regular is tell me the truth
whether I like it or not thank you you
can't do that in this game no no you
can't no no you can tell me whether I
like it or not 100 I agree and I think
that you need to and sometimes I this is
right
I can't say that you don't care about my
feelings but you will my man will tell
me the truth whether and it's not like I
know how we fit what kind of truths
everything anything bro everything
listen right you know a fact you look
fat look at your face you know like you
got two bits if you did that now he'll
be he'll be in jail for emotional abuse
he'll be on some blog so so auntie I I
agree with you like I I think a lot of
men are afraid to tell women the truth
and I think more women would respect it
if they did but at the same but at the
same time
um modern women I think on some level
like to be lied to and don't want the
truth and they want to be sold a fairy
tale because we've been told our whole
lives were Queens princesses and tens I
realized that because I heard everybody
talking about this lizzo
and I saw lizzo for the first time last
this week
uh big
and I just thought to myself when I had
always talk about lizzo and I just
thought wow is that is that is that her
and I was just surprised that all the
yeah but there are no but there are no
standards for women right so lizzo can
can kind of have a physique that is not
as in line with what we generally
consider fit healthy attractive and
flaunted in this like you know over over
kind of zealous way but men will be
scrutinized for like Leonardo DiCaprio
will be scrutinized for dating like a 25
year old even though he's a grown man
that's a grown woman yeah so I had no
problem with
a a size
which wants to be fat that's her
business I hope she stays healthy I but
me personally I'm skinny and I wouldn't
wear what she's wearing but what but
what I found out that totally shocked me
is that
she can play
the flute she's telling to do it and she
is extremely talented but when I looked
at this woman on there shaking her stuff
and doing her thing
yeah I didn't put the two together and I
thought to myself why didn't you lead
with the fact that
you can really play the flute really
good rather than
at the shaking your stuff and
everybody's following her shaking and
she's leading with that and she's
leading the people away rather than how
did she get
to play the flute so good she must have
studied it or whatever but she's not out
there promoting that for the young
people for the modern people to say do
you know what I studied this I studied
music this is what I'm doing she's
promoting all the things what I would
say as negative when she's got so much
positive to give and that's I think I
can understand that why people are
following her that way I would respect
her more as she went out there and she
like dressed professional as a proper
that's not that's not what the model is
not programmed to do that no forget the
program it's just not cool can I say
something this was known for like trying
to like even
sorry I'm gonna make this point she's
I've heard stories that like she will
sleep with guys and then throw them out
of a room as a power play like I've
heard she's deeply insecure in the way
she she handles herself to me that
sounds like you're trying to be a man in
that you're trying to be like this alpha
male who has his way but you're not a
man you're you're female that's the only
time I saw her was playing the flu I've
never seen anything from her before
except her playing the flute and I was
impressed with her playing the loop I
thought why are you playing the flute
with a swing costume on
[Music]
oh
yeah I do I was just gonna say like I
think that people like Lisa will do
things like this because beauty
standards especially for the woman
reality yeah but no beauty standards
like for or like what a woman wants to
Aspire to look like he's actually based
on the standards that men also you know
set because men like [ __ ] they've
been liking [ __ ] since like maybe
like 80s publicly publicly like through
music through like even culture through
some of the things that are being
showing to us right which means that now
we got to a stage even like my friends
whenever they meet a guy first thing
they do is check who they're following
because that shows you like really most
a lot of men promote the [ __ ] culture
so I know that obviously modern women
have to take accountability but I think
it goes both ways and women like Lisa
are literally showing okay well I'm fat
and I'm all of this but if this is the
beauty standards out there I'm not gonna
let my body stop me I'm gonna be wearing
this the same thing that every guy
thinks is wrong why is it promoting it
no man's making a go out there she's
trying to set those standards and stupid
people are following her and then
they're going to turn around and say oh
it's self-love obesity yourself love all
of a sudden and that's what she's
promoting but it's a man's not a man I
don't think she's abused I think she's
generally like just like a wider friend
no she's not why the family she's a
blood she's got one dinosaur I feel like
she looks like someone like she can't no
matter what she does she would still
have like a very wise no she should tone
um
she seems like she squats out no she's
she's cute come on she's pretended she's
potentially um she's potentially
clinically obese but she you can be
obese and healthy yes yeah you can be a
fit her bees and you can also be a very
unhealthy
um skinny skinny person I got a hotel so
she's probably she's probably
metabolically She's metabolically Fit
because for her to play the flip like
that with those long dance jump up and
down despite
despite the size but then if you take
height and weight and do the calculation
she's probably
I just genuinely don't believe you can
be big for that long I'm not going to
pretend I'm a science through a
nutrition like nothing but like I I
genuinely don't believe you can be big
for that long and not have health issues
must be putting a lot of strain on her
heart eventually potentially yeah but
she's better off than someone who's
completely sedentary she's mobile she's
mobile does that make sense but then now
it's yeah but anyways oh sorry I
remember what I wanted to say Alex sorry
the only thing I wanted to say is that
why Lisa did not lead with them
um the flute and everything because
education is not valid these days as
well guys just so you people know it's
not cool to go to UNI I am Juicy J I am
a host and presenter for enercover
afrobeats events but nobody knows I did
my masters nobody knows I do undergrad
nobody knows I'm a stem student and now
I'm a BSC and I'm Australia geek no one
knows that no one cares for that no one
asks that was a fun fact why didn't you
say it
because it's boring because it's boring
modern people think it's boring I found
that I find it really fascinating and
that for me that's something you should
lead with that's true guys there's a
special not special that is something be
careful everybody that is something no
no everybody
exactly by the same time as a black
woman and you're now what you're
educated double educated you're you know
this that you want to be you scared man
away guys I want to get married
no no no but that's what Society no
that's what society makes
you scared by that unless you act like
you're better than them because of it no
but thank you no man no an average guy
can beat you up no man is intimidated by
you no no physically not physically but
I have had people no people come to me
and tell me they're intimidated
and I look at them and I'm like excuse
me they're not the ones for you no of
course they're not you can't be
intimidated with me
I love my energy but when women say this
to you that what does that typically
mean well it means like she's she's mad
egotistical when they say like Mana
intimidated it might be this and that
and it's men judge you by your body
language and like how feminine you are
and so if if God is looking at you being
like I'm intimidated because of like a
degree or something like that I've never
met a guy who gave a flying [ __ ] yeah
anything no one ever no one cares I
think it's the top people that say there
are always people who behave in a way
that creates that image and then they
say oh it's because I'm a woman because
I'm this and that that's my experience
no okay but I'm saying to you that I
don't wake up like this okay I came here
even just be myself not here as in here
here to the UK in general even the way I
speak because I speak with an Italian
mentality to say it's rude it's too
strong it's too forward and a lot of
people don't cannot work with that you
understand I'm not saying that I'm
intimidating I'm saying I'm being told
I'm intimidating I don't think I am not
the numbers
if you understand if you understand
enough that it's like part of your
Italian habits it habits from another
language then surely you can just like
you know solve for value and be like all
right I'll adjust there's a lot of
Italians there who manage to not be seen
as rude it's very difficult it's not
it's not you see nice adjusting yourself
so I have to be myself have self-love
Instead at the same time I just myself
like this is why this Society is going
to Baba this is another policy I have to
be myself I appreciate myself I have
self-care but sometimes I need to adjust
I don't understand
now when you're saying about the Italian
news I've got money in front of she's
Italian yeah and she's the most common
no no husband about
is that by no difference I'm just
talking about adjusting yourself as an
Italian yeah because Italian is who you
are the culture and all of the the
fieriness is something that can be toned
down so that's what I'm asking about
what is it about your Italian
intimidating sometimes it's also
original Regional people from like the
South or from Rome and stuff sometimes a
bit different but it's just how the tone
of voice comes out is not really what
I'm saying
I can speak to me a lot of Italian
people say I'm passionate when they do
yeah yeah and people will take that the
wrong way as arrogant ignorant and loud
but I just think they're passionate yeah
exactly that's exactly that's exactly
but but I think I think that's like a
lack of femininity that's like I think
like typically when when I hear girls
say this and some some behavior that
they do that's like a lack of femininity
to men and that's what's putting them
off well I've never heard that before
I'm absolutely
no no in the sense
myself even what she said like and this
is someone like I can be loud too I'm
not I'm not above it but I'm I'm just
saying like when when she said like loud
like the traits that Auntie just used
that that's not none of them are
feminine traits and so men don't
typically like loud girls you know I was
me I talk okay My Italian Friend my
Italian friend's been married for years
she's gone in and she's Italian and I've
never heard of Razor I've never heard a
razor turn the voice yeah she is just so
humbling she is just so
feminine her and her husband
I don't know they're just perfect
together he looks at her like every time
he sees her I look at him they live
together they've been together for years
and they've got three beautiful and he
looks at her like as if it was the first
day he met her when he looks at her he's
in La it's like the love is in there and
when I'll see her and she's only tiny
and when I'll see her in her little
trainers and I say to her hey are you
looking what's your husband saying
because you're losing a bit of weight
you're looking a bit sexy she's 55. that
was when I made a birthday cake for and
her and her husband even though they're
both Italian they're the most
humbles most quietest most
undercover sexiest people thank you they
know undercover sexy because you can
just see that they've got that sexiness
deep inside of them
um I do want to add quickly though that
that fallacy is that's a fallacy and I
see this a lot in the black community
where you know a lot of the time
black women and a lot of black community
know up the pain points and
communication and there's always a
defensive kind of like oh it's
self-editing just you know if if I kind
of calm myself down and understand this
that it's me not loving myself and
there's all this pushback and you
realize feminine women don't really do
that like feminine women like watch
their calm they're very careful with
their tone you know they fit into every
conversation and I think that's
something as a community we need to we
need to promote that those kind of
values like you can be a classy black
woman who's not loud who's kind of you
know Suave about how you engage yourself
it's not it doesn't mean you're not you
don't love yourself
the modern women want to have some of
that then they should do what I do and
mix with because I I find that a lot of
people who have negative
ideas about marriage is because they
have no positive role models of marriage
and if they even if they nowadays I've
realized that modern people even if
their parents are together and they
parents have like they're still married
they're looking at their parents
relationship or something negative when
it should be something you know they
might think oh my dad tells my mum what
to do or my mom was just a housewife and
they've seen it as something negative
where it's something positive so me
personally when I now even though I'm
I'm content with my man I still surround
myself with happily married feminine
women and their husbands and their
families because I sort of I'm like a
sponge I just want to jump in the middle
and soak it all up yeah I tell you I'm
gonna do that as well okay
um I'm gonna it's gonna kind of late so
I'm gonna
um take a second to read Super Chat and
then we're gonna do final thoughts so
anything you want to speak your piece on
um don't don't go on too long you know
but we're we're gonna give you a chance
to speak at the end so
um thank you guys for all of the
donations this show um it really helps
us fund the new camera that we're trying
to get we're trying to shoot in 8k
um blessing are we gonna be able to
stream in 8k at some point
oh no okay it's just it's for reaction
videos
um I really want to be able to see the
freckles on my face when I do reactions
I don't have a lot I have a few though
and I feel like yeah it's gonna be cool
okay and we're just doing the 10 or more
um I also heard you guys that you want
um the super chats to be put on the
screen if they're less than ten dollars
and we're working on that hopefully we
can get that implemented by what like
next week maybe
yeah so um that is coming another thing
that we also want to implement is the
top um Super Chat of the show we want to
actually put like your super chat on the
wall for the next show so we're not
going to start that this show but next
show whatever
um you guys top Super Chat we can like
write it on a piece of paper and put it
behind me during the next show
yeah you're cool with that okay I talked
to Kobe about it I don't know okay
um that's it Super Chat what happens
when a large part of men get a woman
from abroad piece from d e
um the most Humane thing to let modern
women do is suffer alone until they ask
for help or become a statistic for a
lifelong usage of antidepressants
occasion the most basic way to a man's
heart is food and sex you do that you're
like 90 of the way there it's literally
that easy nearly everything else is just
a bonus blackest Panther women have no
idea how to be romantic when a woman
says she's romantic she's not talking
about she's talking about what she has
done for her not what she does for her
man women think men like date nights
just give us some peace and some PS5
um zero Fallout the generation of ladies
and the laws that are pitiful Auntie my
advice is to go over season to stay
there
um only when the economy stalls and
infrastructure collapses will Western
women realize men do a lot Matt butcher
incredible show guys some perfect
examples of what not to waste your time
on become successful on your own and
give a lady a chance and she shows her
as walk scorched Earth's urge next
um Doug MPA Alex called Lakers jersey
feminine yesterday and sound and be
sounding like a blue pilled simp today
Alex Alex you gotta hold an L today beta
blue pill energy the whole show we see
right through you right now
um Andre Draya most men won't want a 304
as a girlfriend or a wife Purity matters
or at least a low body count preferably
under five that's why most older women
don't find any serious relationships
they'll end up with a cat Lawrence ask
the woman in the blue if she's ever
heard of Mary Kay um let or something if
she wants to give examples of an extreme
OJ didn't do it hearing her talk hate to
say it fellas but we are doomed
lyrically inclined toxic masculinity
definition is when females are masculine
toxic femininity is when males are
feminine that what makes masculinity and
femininity toxic is the fact that it
goes against the nature of the opposite
sex Gregory it's just it's suspicious to
me when a woman is quick to call a man
weak weak men know better than to call
another and stronger man weak and a real
man who is strong doesn't feel the need
to call another man weak
and as acts I'm not excusing it but if a
dude hits you and you're able to hit
back and he he didn't really hit you in
other words when I hear stories like
that and she's not her I assume she was
the one hitting John the Baptist stay in
your lane as a woman John the Baptist
the lady in the blue doesn't want her
man out to hit that Let me refresh this
just to make sure that there's no more
also guys make sure you like the video
that is the most important metric that
YouTube uses to push out these streams
so like the video I want to say we have
1 700 likes which is a great improvement
from last time we'll do a clap for that
well let's try to get to 2 000 likes
before the show ends just so we can push
this out in the algorithm when you guys
like it it sends to YouTube that it's
higher engagement with the stream so
even once the stream is done it really
helps push it out black is Panther being
feminine is not just about appearance
and attire also body language posture
gate and walk mannerisms diet vocal tone
volume how much you speak words word
choice lifestyle and most important your
mentality okay that's all of the super
chats so um go around give your final
thoughts start here go around and then
back row
oh you don't want to start you can see
you
well I still see you oh yeah start from
start from the engine oh sorry okay you
can you can start final thoughts on on
like yeah just the show anything you
want to speak your piece on Now's the
Time and you guys can plug your insta's
social media if you sell something now's
your time
Tandy Blues Blues Tick Tock and
Instagram and based what I didn't get to
say about the abuse punch in if you're
one of them guys that don't well if a
woman hits when we were talking about
from a woman hits you and some guys are
like I'll punch back and someone like oh
don't to the ones that say I don't just
get your female [ __ ] to do the job
that's it definitely
um I'm so happy today I didn't get as
much hate as I normally get so that was
good do follow me the novel dot a o my
final thoughts are boys you need to
become mustache women since obviously
now we also make money also do this
sometimes treat the boys a little bit
more and take the first step there's
nothing wrong
what's up guys the girl Juicy J you can
find me at JC underscore gcj Instagram
tips no yeah Tick Tock and that's it and
last take I don't take all advice you
see on social media because we don't
know where their sources come from
that's all I got to say because this
conversation was amazing thank you very
much Thomas bro yeah thanks I would be
back we can also do something with food
I'd love that yeah my reading trees
don't take advice for everyone on social
media because they may not have a
protocol you don't know where they're
reading the sources their facts and
everything like that that's
misinformation where yeah teach me Teach
Me okra oh my God that's so easy
actually to me so so easy
Auntie what was the word that you were
using
earlier that it's good to be it's been
Swedish no no no traditional
traditionally Street okay so there's a
difference between being traditional and
traditionalists yes which I 100 agree
with so I would say that I am a
traditional listened yes even though I
am not pure yes I like to keep my
Traditional Values alive even though I
have done for a few years but I have
snapped into the fact that I have to
settle down so these traits I want to
you know carry them forward in in the
relationship I am now bless you baby
um
so yes I 100 believe that and I believe
that you have to be
if you are with the right person you
will automatically fall into your
feminine feminine energy and he will
fall into his masculinity yeah and then
it will work but you will 100 be as a
woman you have to go through these frogs
you have to go through the frogs that
are going to put you through hell the
ones that are going to be toxic the ones
are probably going to hit you even
though they shouldn't until you get to
the to this to this right amazing person
um
I have a lot to say but maybe another
time
um my name is lucerito Kami and it's
with the Zed and that's on Instagram you
can catch me that's the only platform I
actually use and it's been amazing to be
on here and also
I'm a salsa dancer and I don't know if
any of the viewers want to see Pearl do
some sales
I I only have one dance move and it's
the shimmy it's the show yeah oh I like
that I'm open to learning more if anyone
wants to see I did doing some stuff I
didn't I do send the messages over
because I could get her too
thousand lesson of Life School we all
learned salsa dancing actually I think
dance school would be good for a lot of
people because it would teach the man to
lead and the woman to follow yes I just
don't know I don't mind that but I just
thought no no maybe not I like both of
them no it's just dancing
I don't like it but you know in dancing
in general is the man that is closer
than something I know you're basically
hanging on his leg I know well I love
seeing my sister sitting on his legs
I've got people that do it but I and
Sarah's good at that Sarah yeah Sarah
Garvey yeah we should get him and and
pearl to do because Sarah does got um
but he's going to hold you quite low on
the waist I'm just telling you now I'm
not saying they dance together I won't
put Pearl through them
[Laughter]
it's burn you're good I would like to
say this is my first time on the show
and I loved it like for me my favorite
is when how Auntie was kicking off I was
like God damn if y'all see this from the
beginning see my face I said damn she
might be my mother you know what I'm
saying but all I would say yeah this
this show was a Vibe and also obviously
if you want to know why we in the world
trust me just chat find me on social
media then you understand the reason why
that's all Mr underscore trust me space
just like this correct it make sure you
spit it right underscore photograph then
you see the reason why the copy Mr trust
me
[Music]
um
Alexander uh
my final thoughts on this are uh was it
missandry talk to masculinity there's no
such thing I think it's just you know
toxic traits I think
um you know we all we all have a lot to
learn I think we you know we're in a
period where we have to like renegotiate
a lot of relationships I'm not as much a
traditionalist as a lot of people on
this panel or maybe some some of the
viewers maybe
um but I am on a mission as a dating
coach to to kind of support as many men
in regaining that kind of masculine
Powers we used to have and I've
definitely noticed a really strong
decline in men just not having the same
values men being raised around women and
having a lot of female talking points
and mannerisms and like that I have I
have some of them as well and I probably
still do but I definitely believe in
like trying to hold the people around me
accountable if I see people being weak
or not valuing themselves
um you know I make a point as a man to
try a man to try and lift each other up
so hit me up on Instagram
um that that's one of my new things on
the side and uh hopefully you know we
can all grow together and be better man
nothing
I didn't lose it if the Italians could
be passionate so can I Auntie you're
perfect
and all I want to say is
someone who hits you hit them back now
baby I have somebody here knock that
[ __ ] out knock that [ __ ] out if a
woman slaps you a man if your hand is
bitter give up I'm not saying I'm not
saying beat her hey she gives you one
slap give her one bit slap back you can
even give her two no I slap for SNAP so
every time she slaps you slap her back
your woman is abusing you
make sure you're in if you're in the UK
there's cameras everywhere make sure
that when she hits you that it's on the
camera let her hit you about three or
four times and just hit her once but
make sure that it's on the camera or
make sure that somebody's reporting it
and
women you don't need to be scared of men
but man
I think you should be scared of women
that's my final thought also I'm
Auntie's new YouTube channel is in the
description hey so um she's already at a
thousand subscribers we're trying to get
her monetized so if you guys want to go
subscribe to that and then we're
actually going to start having lives
where um Auntie has her own show on the
channel so can I just say something yeah
um on the the first show that I've done
when I sat in for you even though you
look really good as a black woman
um
the interruptions I spoke to my
granddaughter and I told her that I was
on TV she's five years old and she asked
me how it was and I said that all the
young people there kept on talking over
each other
she said Grandma they didn't even say
excuse me so
um
I'm not putting up with it anymore
from the mouths of babes if my
granddaughters are over talking me she'd
get a warning and then she'd have to
leave
and
that's what I'm going to be doing
because I'm not going to be disrespected
by anyone when I'm when I'm when I'm
hosting my own show so if you come onto
the show and you disrespect me
I'm going to ask you to I'm going to
give you a warning and I'm going to ask
you to leave I'm even thinking about
getting the referee cards Yellow cards
and red cards too many yellow cars and
then you're out and that's what I intend
to do because
going back to decisional if my
five-year-old granddaughter can see that
overtalking people is wrong and she's
going to look down on me for accepting
it I'm not going to allow her to look
down on me I'm not accepting it from
nobody I wouldn't accept it from anybody
older than me and I'm definitely not
going to expect to accept it from
youngsters so anybody that comes onto my
show and expects to overtalk me
and you think I lost it
don't mess with me I'm not gonna put up
with it I'm going to show you the door
tell them Auntie respectfully I've
learned that
um okay I'm gonna read the last couple
of super chats before we close out the
show guys like the video for a like this
video that is the number one metric that
YouTube uses to push out these streams
also
um consider signing up for our
memberships um we do members only Chats
on here sometimes um on top of that the
10 tier you get access to our Discord
which I'm now very active in I'll be
like chatting after the shows and and
you get to see our behind the scenes
Vlogs um if you ever wanted to see me
rap
I do rap and No One Believes Me but it's
on one of our behind the scenes Vlogs so
ten dollar tier on guitar playing is
better
and I've seen you play the guitar as
well yeah my guitar is better I I I'm a
woman of many talents
um third okay that's ten dollar tier
um third tier is you get to connect with
me on social media and the fourth tier
is a one-on-one call with me once a
month I am really good at helping people
grow their YouTube channels um I have
helped multiple people grow their
YouTube channels to get to 10 20 30 that
oh [ __ ] my bad my bad 30 000 subscribers
so make sure you go do that if you want
to grow on YouTube I think that's where
you get the most bang for your buck
um okay just something the girl in the
blue needs to re-watch these videos
she's constantly talking down to people
because of imaginary Authority it's
really baffling to watch her like this
after Pearl read the description of a
narcissist it's her Tyrell Clark how are
you a single mother and a traditionalist
Haram
um blackest Panther being feminine is
not about appear okay Brothers already
okay guys um again thank you so much for
watching um another thing go follow my
Instagram just dot pearly things you
have to type out the whole thing because
my Instagram is Shadow band
um also go follow my two tick tocks just
probably things dot four and just
probably things dot five I'm on my final
account warning for just probably things
four so go follow five in case that gets
taken subscribe to the channel because I
really want to hit a hundred thousand or
um 500 000 subscribers before the end of
the month that is the goal
um DM Eddie if you want to come on the
show and we're gonna have a members only
live stream um in the next two weeks
once we're done with our studio and
we're going to be doing a behind the
scenes Vlog of the new penthouse that's
still coming I know I've been promising
it for a while but we're still doing
Studio updates so I just want to wait
till it's done
um like the video on your way out and we
will talk to you next time
[Music]
my ears
are flat